[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans I'm here with one of
the competitors in the upcoming all-in
match Jonathan vs. Caleb Jonathan Krantz
one of the foremost YouTube chess
personalities Jonathan you are the lower
rated player in this match against Caleb
Denby do you consider yourself the
underdog absolutely not I'm really
looking forward to this
this event yeah I know I'm lower rated
and it's I have to be honest though it's
been a long time since I've been this
motivated to get into a match and I'm
really looking forward to getting into
it with Caleb I'm taking this very
seriously
I'm training really hard I wake up in
the morning and I'm thinking about this
match I'm ready to totally take him on
and I think I should be able to take him
down I know that nobody wants to think
about losing a match but would losing to
Caleb hurt your reputation in the chess
community it would destroy me yeah
absolutely cannot lose to this guy I'm
putting too much work into this
I'm trying every second of every day
this is all I'm focused on is winning
this match and I'm gonna do it I'm
sitting here with Caleb Denby one of the
participants in the upcoming strong
expert chess match titled Jonathan vs.
Caleb this is gonna be one for the ages
and it's not too much further from now
is a Caleb what do you think your
expectations are in this match what are
your chances to win against Jonathan
well I fully expect to win I'm not sure
why Jonathan actually agreed to this I
don't think he really stands a chance at
all of doing this so I you know I always
felt like more of a joke to me that and
I'm kind of surprised he's willing to go
through this I understand you're working
with a very special member of the chess
community Dennis LaRue with your prep
tell us a little bit what can you share
with us Caleb well Dennis had a very
interesting approach it was definitely
the most exhausting prep I've ever done
for anything in my life well as Austin
is not something you usually hear with
this kind of matchup what exactly can
you share with us uh yeah I mean I don't
want to go into too many details or
anything but yeah I mean we we worked
very hard to prepare for this match and
you know I spent a lot of time a lot of
early mornings working working to get
here as I understand we have some video
footage of your training camp and we're
gonna take a look at it right now
Dennis listen Kaleb Jonathan it's best
it's fast like grease might be we want
to beat him you're gonna need speed does
I'm not gonna chase this chicken around
feel like a Kentucky Fried idiot all
right you ready to do some speed
training hi I guess let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait around for I didn't hear no Bell
[Music]
to you what is on the line
truthfully in this match you talk a big
game Caleb but what is on the line for
you well I mean just my reputation as as
chess club staff champion I've
definitely went all in preparing for
this match and yeah I just I refuse to
lose with this rapid in blitz match it's
coming up awfully quick do you feel like
you're ready for Caleb there's nothing
I've ever been more ready for than in my
life this is what I've been dreaming of
every day for the last couple months and
I have to say I'm all-in
you
[Music]
and we are live welcome back to st.
Louis everybody for a very special event
my name is Ben Simon and I'm joined by
Grandmaster Denish barouche and we are
here for a match about six months in the
making at least this is all in Jonathan
vs. Caleb the strongest chess expert
level match in history Barasch are you
excited for today for six draws always
well it could be although it's kind of
unlikely so if you've been following our
YouTube channel for any amount of time
you're familiar with this man
Jonathan schranz Jonathan schranz born
1988 30 years old a longtime staff
member of the st. Louis chess club he
played his first tournament in 2011 and
today it's important to note that three
USCF ratings will be on the line though
regular for a classical the Blitz and in
between the quick rating and his ratings
are as follows Jonathan trance has a
USCF classical of 1875 a quick of 1706
but oddly enough his blitz is 2026 so
he's an awesome blitz player although
he's never won anything but he's come
close so maybe he should wait till his
time hits five minutes and start playing
yeah well we'll be looking at the format
in just a bit but he's going to be
hoping that blitz definitely pulls him
through in this match trout's grew up in
San Diego and then went to college at
st. Louis University's campus in Madrid
Spain I guess he likes Lou so much he
came to the real Saint Louis afterward
and started work here at the st. Louis
chess club now the thing about Jonathan
he's a serious chess player as you saw
in that opening montage he was booking
it up he was talking with grandmaster
pepe cuenca but also i noticed we may
have exposed his prep a little bit
unfortunately i don't know if we got
anything for that but hopefully caleb
didn't see it to keep this match on the
up and up I really hope seen
lot of chicken we didn't wait yeah on
the other side if we have Caleb
available we can talk about him I don't
know if he's in the tournament hall as
of yet
Caleb Denby only 20 years old just had
his birthday last month he is running
this extremely popular YouTube series on
Wednesday nights where he gets you on
the road to 2000 and today he wants to
school Jonathan shots on his road to
2000 Caleb Denby played his first
tournament actually before Jonathan back
in 2010 his USCF ratings are well it's
funny because they're a little bit
similar to Jonathan's situation that you
see Caleb there with the chicken that he
caught in that montage he is the 2019
staff tournament champion we had that
tournament back in January he was the
clear winner his classical is 21 33 USCF
and his rapid and blitz ratings us CFR
18 14 and then blitz of course is higher
than the quick in 1987 and he Caleb has
lived in the st. Louis area his entire
life he attended Highland High School
just on the edge of the metro area over
in Metro East Illinois now about Caleb
I asked going into this match if he was
prepping the right way and I asked him
if he could share any insights into his
training methods and then I saw that
footage real throwback Mickey gold mill
rocky 2 and we saw how rocky 2 ended and
it could mean good things for mr. Denby
so the players are upstairs in the
tournament hall preparing for their
match and in just a moment we're going
to be looking at exactly what's on the
line and our match format and how
exactly this will be contested now as
far as the match format goes we will
have a combination of rapid and blitz
games there will be two rapid games to
start and the time control for those our
game in 25 minutes with a five-second
delay and that's the only delay you're
gonna see all day okay and they're
starting here but I'm gonna keep going
over the format before we get to the
game
we will have for blitz games after that
and if necessary we will have one
Armageddon at the end now the way that
these games are weighted each rapid game
is worth two points there you see there
each one of those rapid games game in 25
five-second delay it's worth two points
one point will get you
you'll get that from a draw as far as
the Blitz games each one of those is
worth one point and a half point for a
draw so eight points total on the line
here and the first person to clinch
four-and-a-half points is the winner
then the match is over so by if one
person sweeps the both rapid games then
we will it could take just one blitz
game to end the match if it's a clean
sweep of course you don't really want
that to happen so it looks like the
players have started their games we want
to remind you that the social media chat
is open in on our YouTube channel this
is exclusively on YouTube and okay so
we're gonna get a closer look at the
board here in just a moment we're
getting these microphones fixed here the
studio so you guys can hear us so it's
interesting to note Mike comer called in
today and while he's off work today he
said that Caleb Denby is the heavy
favorite I think he said a three to one
Suites and one to one favorite now he is
higher rated and Caleb Bennett he also
has a feed a and universal rating a
classical feed a that is universal
rating system counts classical rapid and
blitz
he's a 2009 but it's really tough you
can't really compare much here because
Jonathan doesn't have one of those but
we have some lines here okay and it's
the Carl Kong [ __ ]
she's not chucking at all big big
preparation by the vampire chicken which
is what Jonathan goes by John line yes I
am I wonder why
Caleb was chasing a chicken bone good
question because both of them like
chickens have you seen lucky to Dennis
yeah I have okay oh my god
[Laughter]
we're off to a smashing start I mean
cozy aren't up to ya get in the frame
here so what do we have here so far so
so far all theory both of them seem to
be booked up and they're following the
old old match World Championship match
played between kramnik and Lake oh is it
2004 2004 Brits ago if you like our
company then you might have visited the
match and got some for free actually I'm
not sure about that one but so anyways
they're following the main line so far
oh is that nine jump jumping backwards
no okay
it was just a little bit of a glitch
what why is that not going backwards
well there we have a shot of the live
board is that accurate yes okay so so
far so good
Bishop e7 is not Deline what Lake Oh
played Lake Oh played Queen c7 and went
for the classical run which ended in a
draw that game actually two of them were
played before so what is your
expectation will we see blood in this
first round I think that we're not gonna
see a lot of draws in this entire match
really yes I I think that this is going
to be quite decisive
now Caleb's been kind of goofing off
right he's the staff tournament champion
now we were talking about rocky - he
might be in like rocky and rocky 3 like
the early part of that you know and
things didn't go well for Rocky and
so we got to see if he is taking
Jonathan lightly Jonathan has been
talking with every GM in res we've had
here at the st. Louis chess club and I
mean more than just Pepe we got Pepe on
video there but it might be some more
insight into Jonathan's opening prep but
besides that what we have here is a tale
of age experience and the youth
I mean look Caleb hasn't topped out yet
he's we don't know what his limitations
are at just 20 years old he's one of the
most well-spoken best instructors we
have here at the st. Louis chess club I
think he's too good to be true
you think he oh you think yes oh hype
yes okay he's just a sweet talker that
he's supposed to like but I think
there's a deeper truth beneath that look
at look at that guy who's bearded I mean
Jonathan yes that guy that man
yes he's he shows no emotions perfect
player wonderful you get a closer look
at at the board from this angle because
this is a very intriguing moment of
seeing the look on Jonathan's face he
said that if he loses this match
it would crush him it would devastate
him his reputation cleated done I can
see that just look just close up onto
his face that look those eyes are
fixated at the board
he might be crying no hey we've got a
very active chat we want to thank all of
you for joining us former manager of the
st. Louis chess club Alex Marlar said he
is so excited he took off work today to
watch this match
atta boy how about that hello in
Baltimore Colin Meyer says go Caleb and
piggy pig-pig
is here as always so about the analysis
either play or have it
right here bullsh well actually we have
to catch up a little bit let's do that
so they went for a classical mainline
takes let me update my computer it takes
between d5 so Caleb here is trying to
exchange Queens because he's behind
space so he wants to exchange pieces
because he's way behind development on
the other hand Jonathan is trying to
checkmate
so he goes Bishop III and says no
exchanges for you I'm gonna destroy you
and you can feel the tension
look how caleb is thinking he's like oh
my god
he's going to make me oh my goodness
that dramatical yeah like people don't
don't talk about these emotions that we
show and this is a very emotional match
yes it's the most some bad blood in here
these guys have had a feud here in the
st. Louis chess club that we are
settling here today and I got it I got
to mention something I talked about all
the three different ratings before and
and I actually skipped something since
they started a little prematurely the
the there are two time controls that
we're seeing here in regulation the game
in 25 with a five delay and then blitz
is five minutes no delay no increment
it's sudden death it's gonna get crazy
and we're just gonna have to zoom it on
the board because the dgt will be
useless when we're going that fast it's
gonna be crazy but my point is the Blitz
will be rated USCF blitz the 25 with a 5
will be rated USCF regular and quick or
what we call classical and ram those
that urs rated no this will not be rated
by fidei or the universal rating system
and it's simply because we we don't have
all of the we don't have matching all
ratings to go head-to-head with each
other so this will be USC up rated we
want to mention that our chief arbiter
is Sam Troy get up in the tournament
Hollies all decked out in a suit and tie
looks
a bit like me you know we know how to
style in profile he's making sure
everything is running smoothly one I
should give a shout-out to Sam choy Ken
so back to the game so we've got an
aggressive move by Caleb trying to gain
more space and attack
Jonathan's King but um Jonathan doesn't
look impressed he looks at Caleb and
says buddy I'll be faster than you and
he's just basking in the glory of his
position right now Lyle you can see how
Caleb is praying okay I'm just praying
hands like please don't check made me a
very observant yes I know like
psychology is actually overlooked in
this game and Caleb might show more than
he usually does that's like when you
look at people or softly spoken they
have a lot to hide I also want to
mention that Jonathan it has just
arrived
back in town after a 15 to 18 hour car
ride he was down in Florida with his
family and he made it just back in the
nick of time for this match there's so
many X factors have been traumatic I
have no idea I mean it's tiring at the
very least the thing is he's back and he
said he's ready to play we said hey he's
gonna make it man you're gonna make it I
mean it just in the nick of time but
he's got to be tired he's got to be
exhausted that's got to take its toll
and he's the underdog in this match but
there's no excuses even though I'm
making them right now it's winner take
all
I mean he did play the boss move 95
which actually signals that hey man I'm
here for all the marbles
and you can see you can see caleb is
under some pressure he's trying to
defend his neck just like a true
Highlander because you know one chopped
and there can be only one yes
I'm not even sure what Caleb will do
here and I'm not even sure he knows
what's your take on that
am I just exaggerating all these
feelings sue Caleb I think so I think
honestly I think so because caleb is is
a very sound mind he's very calm and
although his regimen was a little odd
with the chicken we I think he is taking
this seriously right now as seriously as
you can take this this rapid or quick
game it's a difference of terminology by
the way a quick USCF rapid feed a
everything should use active for rapid
sometimes our action chess yeah actually
when I was playing in scholastic chess
gateway chess like I played with Caleb
Denby he's like 10 years younger than me
but we both played in the Kate way
Chesley and yeah there's those action
tournaments game in 30 so yeah it has a
different lot of different terminologies
wikipedia says Oh to heck with it we're
just calling it fast chess and that's
what we're playing today so actually
jonathan is giving this g2 pong away and
he tries to look as bored as possible
saying oh i blundered upon please take
it take my pawn cuz if Caleb would take
on g2 then Jonathan go would go rawr and
attack on the G line that would open up
but I'm not sure that Caleb will take it
but notice the time difference Jonathan
is up 21 minutes while dembe's only 19
minutes and he's still thinking and I
think he's out of book you know I bet
you that Caleb isn't even thinking of
taking that G to pawn why not so juice
is too obvious come on you're selling
Caleb short but that's a juicy pawn
I love juicy pawns anything could happen
in this match in our chat a club
employee upstairs Nick risco says
Jonathan loses if Jonathan loses he
should shave off the beard if Caleb
loses
grow his hair back out why didn't we
think of that I mean he would have liked
a Rastafari hair yeah you remember how
Caleb Caleb used to have a kind of big
shaggy hair mm-hmm I still would go to
Jamaican style I I preferred the gym
harder to do I know but it's cooler so
it is there anything any revelations in
this game or anything so this Jonathan
has a three minute leave right now yeah
I think Jonathan you need to enjoy your
moment you're torturing your opponent he
can barely move and actually Caleb
played the move before trying really
hard to checkmate Jonathan which will
not happen or shouldn't happen so this
is going to be basically a race between
the two sides who's faster
White is trying to mount the pawns and
go g4 g5y Blackwell to the opposite and
go a5 a4 and a3 so I'm honestly putting
my money on Jonathan he's well prepares
he's confident I don't see a reason why
Jonathan wouldn't win this game it's
everything the game here for Jonathan
and a longtime viewers of the st. Louis
chess club YouTube channel know that
Jonathan gained fame as the host of
chess openings explained yes I think
back in 2015 is when he started that
series and for about 2 years give or
take a few months or something
he went over obscure openings main lines
sidelines and he would prep for so long
like we saw in the intro he would book
up on these things he would put at least
I'm not exaggerating at least 10 to 12
hours prep to each class that we would
have on Monday nights here at the club
and you know I kind of miss his classes
but the thing is the time that he's had
away we don't know about his progress we
don't know what he's bringing to the
table in this match against Caleb so it
could work in his favor yeah he's been
repairing in the shadows and
you know just keeping the boxing
terminology I would give huge points for
him he won this basic getting into this
match I feel I feel Jonathan's ready
he gets what the technical point of what
he gets the advantage for sure okay he's
out there he's swinging and Caleb is
like don't hit me don't hit me and he's
in full full defensive that b4 is like a
counter punch it's not it's not a true
threat and yes Jonathan goes I know
you're joking
that b4 is just a meme let's go g4 and
he goes g4 94 well he's trying to defend
actively even maybe trying tricks of
nights eats me but it's just a mirage
it's not really a big threat yet so I'd
still think that this is a big attack
for Jonathan yeah actually what Alex or
no not Alex 42 is answer oh that's a
nice username we all know that's the
answer is the oyster in our YouTube chat
says the 10 part full semi slob series
that Jonathan did as part of chess
openings explained is legendary and I
agree I actually didn't think we would
finish it all I thought you know you
know because people start a project and
they lose interest and no we went all
the way through a ten-part semi slob
series it's it's something else you
should definitely check it out later on
today
I think I think Jonathan is thinking now
how should I wrap this game up
should I go easy on him just look at him
should I be going easy should I check
made him now so you really have no
confidence in Caleb in this game
you think it's not doing much not much I
think
if Jonathan does it correctly and
defends the
illusions that's around his kings King I
think that he'd have a chance to wrap
this game win and that this game is
worth two points I remember this is a
dual stage match here rapid and blitz
two rapid games worth two points each
one point for a draw and then the blitz
is worth one point each half point for a
draw so eight points total on the line
first a four and a half is the champion
no more games are played if the match is
tied in regulation four to four we will
have a five minute versus four minute
Armageddon but I would be surprised
honestly if we get there I feel like
this will be decided in regulation
possibly but I still expect draws okay
you see pessimistic no no I observe
ation and I feel hurt honest right and
someone was asking for the USCF ratings
where hey we're exclusively on youtube
right now so I'll tell you straight up
caleb is 2133 USCF and Jonathan is 1875
USCF and we're talking about USCF
ratings because this is only us chess
rated today not fidei no Universal
ratings on the line this is just all
three u.s. chess ratings that will be
affected this is dual rated classical
and rapid actually I have a theory
go ahead I think that Jonathan sit down
as we saw him preparing he must have
been thinking okay I'm out rated in
classical and Rapids but in blitz I have
a hundred points advantage mm-hmm yes so
how would you act in his place would you
try to think as much as possible so
we'll get into the Blitzen or would you
keep it in the classical rapid zone
where you would be behind rating points
well it's definitely got to be a
confidence boost for him going into the
Blitz right so even if he's down
coming out of this game in 25 section he
will he will think hey I can probably
get the better part of the four points
four points available to me in the blitz
so so that can work in his favor in that
that way so he took a little time and
played rugby g1 which is a brave move
but very dangerous because black is
ready to attack white now with this
blistering sacrifice on c3 takes takes
and I'm not confident it's winning for
black but it's quite dangerous so I feel
that this move rook DG one might have
been a little bit too slow
so I would have preferred moving the
King to the side just getting ready for
any nasty tricks Caleb would have in his
sleeves but anyways rook DG 1 was played
and now even though I don't like the
move I like the way Jonathan is playing
he loses confidence he plays fast unlike
Thembi who's quite slow and I think
that's going to hunt and bite them be in
the arts later well yeah I mean a
two-minute deficit here in this section
is a little bit more than a two-minute
deficit in a long game so it could make
all the difference but remember they're
still five-second delay so if someone's
down they can play on that delay later
on in the Blitz section there's no delay
there's no increment it's just five
minutes it's like Street chest Street
Street chess that's what they play
outside on the street here in st. Louis
and Creighton Olsen in New York you know
how many fights break out because you
know someone flew a King across the
board or something they Syrians I refuse
I refuse to play five minutes no
increment no delay I absolutely refuse I
will have to play with a delay or it
well because always fights that break
out always disagree oh I can't stand it
hate it
I cannot stand in Sam choy get the
arbiter it has his hands full later on
today
well can he stop both of them at the
same time okay he go man Sam
joy get as far as going by the book
being like a real by-the-book TV he
Mike's not gonna like me saying this he
does remind me a lot of Mike Hummer
because they are definitely by the book
and he knows that rule book so if
someone hits you you said only with one
hand and hit the right clock he knows
everything he knows everything out he
knows how to stop them well we're
talking physical here no call in the big
guns
yes so so anyways I'm I'm thinking that
with the time passing
I like Jonathan's chances more and more
because look at the clock then B has 13
minutes
Jonathan has 17 and if Caleb own
checkmate I think the rating average
will decide what do you think yeah I
think that's a good assessment and one
thing I wanted to talk about we haven't
really touched on it yet is that while
Jonathan has been working with all of
the top grandmasters that have been
around in the club Caleb was working
with Dennis LaRue who also used to teach
tactics time here at the club and is a
YouTube personality in his own right
after the chicken chasing incident I am
told Caleb released Dennis from his
managerial and training contract which
is quite unfortunately mistake name well
you know Caleb big head you know might
let his trainer go maybe it's a good
choice maybe it's a bad choice but it's
a good thing for us because big news
joining us as part of our broadcast team
later on today in his own corner segment
will be the one and only Dennis
lilulu can't wait for that it's gonna be
great good so talking about tactics
Debbie played the rook to b8 which is
the reason he misses LaRue's guidance
now I'm sure LaRue would play Knight c3
take takes and go for checkmate and
whatever happens happens
now rugby eight is a little bit how
should I put it
naive it's like oh I'll just attack and
all Knights III check and I'll be losing
and I'm sure just look at Jonathan now
he's like oh you think you think I don't
see Knight c3 check coming
of course he sees that so where do you
put the Queen oh my god he actually
missed it well what did he do what he do
he actually moves the pawn as far as I
see inviting Caleb to do what he
actually wanted to do is this Leroux
classic night sees me check sacrifice
he's kind of forcing him to do it this
might be the meme of the day okay Knight
c3 check B takes B takes check yeah rook
is now attacking the white king what
happens there
so if the King runs tries to run then
check e on a3 the King goes tries to
flee on the clean side but wait can we
play this on the board I don't know if
it's possible I don't know if oh yes yes
so this should be here and nice little
check and you've got made it my friend
is there any way out of this there is no
way out of this the other the other
tried that I can do is the King gave one
move but here Caleb can tried to
checkmate two ways he can go Ruby to
where Queen c4 kind of saves Jonathan
for the moment but it looks very dicey
to be honest or bring the bishop in here
threatening all kinds of ideas of Bishop
b2 s
and okay but on the surface King a1 is
the superior movie they're not losing
yes you're not losing
immediately but this does look very
dicey so I'm not quite sure I like this
move f3 I would never invite black to
sack even though he might survive but
now this is the big question for Caleb
should he go Knight c3 and try to win on
the spot or play something else and lose
what would you do well based on what
I've seen the knight c3 definitely
Knight c3 is on your agenda and people
in the chat agree Knight c3 in an
instant but bill Knight sees me be the
meme of the day can the chat help the
meme of the day meme of the day I'm sure
there's a chance that you'll have I'm no
longer sure I understand what meme on
the meaning of meme is I don't know any
I don't know anyone who understand memes
up ever so I thought it was a picture
with words on it yeah but I mean this
could become the meme of the day this
Knight c3 alright someone put some words
on that yep and look at Caleb he's
full-on God mode now he's trying to
calculate everything he's trying to
cover his eyes so he can't trick himself
and he's trying to rely on his brain not
his eyes he's brain are you surprised he
hasn't claimed Knight c3 yet I'm a
little surprised yes I think he's still
kind of in shock he's checking not to
play too quickly
I wonder what Jonathan's thinking at
this point like we thought that Jonathan
was in the driver's seat and now it
looks like he may have given the game
away possibly but look we got his poker
face I mean it helps he wears a beard if
you have a bad poker
yes masterful poker face so if you don't
have a poker face grow a beard it
actually helps helps having you build a
new kind of mimic and also it might help
you win games
look he's also playing with his beard
saying oh I I know you're thinking of
night seats me I'm not concerned not at
all but maybe he's also thinking that he
might have missed the tea party today
have tea parties in st. Louis actually
there's a tea tea house up the street on
the street they do have tea parties and
went there one time with my grandma that
was a little embarrassing the tea was
great was very overpriced though I think
that's what Jonathan was thinking did I
miss the Tea Party the Friday Tea Party
made a shot of a I don't know we have
Caleb's face I want to see what he yeah
yes he's been hiding I mean cuz he's
really giving this some thought night
season he has not been played as if he
hasn't been played yet but I mean it
itches to be played there his there it
is the golden Knight c3 just happened
Boros just could be over rather quickly
don't you think well it's possible but
let's wait maybe Jonathan has some huge
defensive ideas mm-hmm yep Knight c3
plate takes takes and now we have to
find the best defensive move King a one
the other one loses immediately do we
have any questions about this game so
far from me from you or the audience to
body chef if you have any questions ask
away in the chat well first of all
people are talking about engines as is
always the topic of conversation and I
know you have a lot of ideas about alpha
zero we have some videos on that but as
far as the chat goes guys we got to tell
you right now
we don't have any engine turned on this
game is not on chest 24 this game is not
on Lee chest this is not anywhere we're
gonna see an evaluation we could turn it
on our computer right now we refuse we
were
we got this guy's brain right here and
he's the best that's all we need
that's all we need anyway if hey if
we're way off we're way off okay there's
a lot of fun so he gave one was played
very good defense so far by Jonathan and
this looks super dangerous I'll be
honest with you I'd be scared I'll be
shaking if I'd be white but look look at
Jonathan he's a model of a super super
player he shows no emotions says I'm
gonna beat you even though I'm lost I'm
still gonna beat you I'm a confident man
I know what I'm doing I don't know about
that you know I don't know I mean look I
think Jonathan look he's drinking water
like he knows what he's doing
yeah his mouth is permit probably really
really dry right now because of the
nerve look heels the ghetto - Jesse
threw it away if if I'd be drinking two
different beverages the same time I I
think I'd be confident well anything can
happen here I mean look at Caleb's time
now he's down but a nine point nine
minute and deficit yes six minutes so
it's actually getting dicey for Caleb
because if he doesn't checkmate I think
we're gonna see a draw to result game
yeah it's dead no way Jonathan's gonna
win this you're great no I'm not I'm not
sure that Jonathan won't win this I'm
saying Caleb bill chickened out at the
last second he's gonna chicken it's good
did you see that there yep so he could
go Bishop III
Knight c4 check now
really enough even king b1 could be an
idea and actually Bishop III was played
man Caleb knows what he's doing
and he's preparing this Bishop b2 check
idea
now there's two way of defending against
this either of it rugby one trying to
sacrifice your rook for the bishop
but that is very very dangerous
like white can defend but that's a
cornered King I don't like that
why did you play Queen Acer so I played
Queen eight six because queen takes a
two five like painful I agree I tend to
avoid pain if possible yeah
Knight c4 I would even consider it
sneaky ideas like Queen B 5 and if let's
say queen d3 let's do the good old good
old rook b8 and be tough to stop this
Ruby rugby one ideas and maybe even
clean a force but actually it would be
one that's quite painful right now so
let's say Queen d1 trying to avoid
checkmate then Queen a4 takes takes and
loss is imminent as the a2 is hanging
now instead of rugby one night c4 is an
idea for some reason I kind of feel Luke
c4 looks like one of the best way to
defend here
although night c4 okay Jonathan has
elected for Bishop c1 bishop c1 defense
I did want to mention though that night
c4 I have this neat little idea of Queen
b5 cuz if you would take on a3 whoops I
take your queen yeah but if you don't do
that
I'll have this sneaky Bishop b2 check
with the same trick
so here checks and probably you'll have
to take with the rook because otherwise
your queen will be hanging and if you
like mating better yeah right nice I
don't even need the Queen you don't even
need the Queen you just check me so
anyway takes takes and Bishop c1 was
played hmm good defense
the best defense it might be the best
defense and if we look at the time
difference John is up a whole 10 minutes
on the clock that's confidence right
there and now caleb is playing a blitz
game yep
fundamentally and if he's playing the
Blitz game you know what that means is
jonathan time it's vampire time vampire
chicken this is a chess comm user i
think isn't yes yeah well known went by
her chicken and caleb is also has a
username online i think it's a is it
llama lord
I think it's llama Lord yeah people
might have seen that on his lectures
when he teaches on Lee chess so it seems
to me the llama Lord pardon me that
Caleb played a move let's see what he
played
we don't have that move yet it looks
like let's see if you can tell what
happened
rook b2 was played Wow something we
haven't looked at at all wow it does
seem that caleb is going all-in hey how
about that he's backing the punches he
learned from those chickens he got a
half speed yes you gotta have squeezy
fast speed but this Bishop c1 move was a
good defense rook b2 is very creative
but I'm not convinced I'm sorry I'm not
convinced at all that this is that good
they have a feeling that and he played
94 very good defensive play
no he played Queen c4 clean c4 actually
had like 9 c4 better trying to exchange
it off
I mean c4 mmm maybe this this won't be a
winner
I think might c4 might have been might
have been a clincher because he was a
fetcher for whom for white Oh Jonathan
Jonathan Schwanz would have had a chance
to win this so but with Queen c4 as then
be correctly played played rook f b8
forcing what we know as odd or explain
explain so if I'd say haha exchange
Queens
then you'd be sadly mistaken I'm sorry
sir
you are sadly mistaken so he has no
choice but to take this little gift
actually maybe you'll have another
choice but takes if you take it as a
pawn
we'll use it as a shelter and white will
just win so Caleb is forced to take what
the bishop King goes back bishop moves
check which is nice it's always nice to
check
now if Jonathan is on suicide mode he
can go Queen b3 but then takes and this
is just an amazing position for black
and I would rather be black because
you're attacking and these rooks are
kind of useless and what I would expect
here is King a1 finding shelter and then
there should be two drawers the only
question I have is what if I move my
bishop instead of taking the b2 rook
which is a brave solution but dicey
let's say something like Bishop III but
that that might be too dangerous after
say look take c2 as Bishop b2 his coming
and in any case even if let's say she
takes d5 I see big play for Caleb here
even though he's down the piece the king
is two cornered so what I'm expecting
here is a draw that's what I expect
Oh in the case of a draw both players
would be awarded one point and does
these two rapid games that start off the
match are double weighted so first a
four and a half total wins of the blitz
games will have four of them later on or
up to four if necessary and each game is
worth one point the match is decided and
ends when one player achieves four and a
half best of eight so Bush I wanted to
ask you actually for yes unless you had
an immediate line oh no I was just
referring that Knight c4 might have been
a little bit more ambitious yes so do
you have history with these players have
you sat down on a board and competed
against them in in a rated environment
no I have never played any of them don't
but I've seen Jonathan and I've seen his
dedication
and I think we're in for a big match
here mm-hmm
actually the whole match will be decided
in the next game
I think if Jonathan will be able to
match Caleb in the next game with the
black color I think we're gonna see a
full-fledged fight well they all come
about comes down to blitz well what's
your take because I heard that you
played some of them I've played them
both they didn't bow never beat either
one of them
not even close really actually when I
played in the gateway chess league
Caleb was just I think he was like in
kindergarten or something our first
grade and it was years later I was
coaching in elementary school chess team
maple wood Richmond Heights and we would
I would take them to the chess
tournaments in the area how that works
it's like it's a Scholastic circuit
actually there's two scholastic circuits
in the area the Chess Club actually has
their own the gateway chess league is
one that complements it and so we were
in the gateway chess League and we'd be
at all these different schools and I'd
be running the st. Louis Chess Club
merchandise table and coaching and all
these kids account they say let's play
let's play let's play I said okay I play
and I beat them you know I mean it's
rare to find a kid over 1200 yeah things
and and then Caleb comes sounding like
who was this kid and he justified I
destroys me so great memories never come
close to beating Caleb so meanwhile
we're heading towards the main line
actually know he decided Jonathan
decided no I'm going all-in
and he went Bishop f4 which we're
waiting to papa
yes and Bishop f4 was played so he says
no I'm gonna beat you you have four
minutes
I'm the blitz expert you're a nobody in
blitz I'm gonna destroy you do you think
it was a wise decision based on what we
seen yeah I mean I think I think it was
a fine decision in
do you feel looking at this that
Jonathan is just still trying to survive
do you have that feeling I kind of feel
that he seems very confident rook takes
see rook takes c2 and we're going to see
a fight here I give full credits for
Jonathan for going for this this one's
way more dangerous but it's not a draw
and he says I don't care I'm going to
destroy him he's under three minutes
soon so probably he says I'll go for
this I'll try my best to beat him hey
guys big news
Nick risco here at the Chess Club has
just posted this game as a leech s study
that's pretty cool so if you want
evaluation and act like you're smarter
than Grandmaster Danish Poros you can
click on that link that he just posted
in the chat and head on over to leech s
where you can see this game in progress
yep there it is I'm looking at it right
now very cool Thank You Nick good job
Nick so actually clean exchange happened
and my assessment was kind of easier to
play for black because even though white
is up a piece we'll get there just a
second Queen d5 takes C takes d5 just
played and even though white is up a
piece he's King is stranded and these
rooks are terrible even if you would try
this one I would come up with this idea
takes rook takes oh you're dead and
you're basically these two rooks yeah
like you could try tricks takes even
hoping for not before which is not even
a threat because let's say I go here
check and I go check and bye-bye they
take your knight I can't even go a five
and say oh okay you don't even have that
trick anymore and you're basically
completely paralyzed here
and I say that caleb is gonna win here
so few more moves above you a few more
moves plaint been played let's see so
we'll be five blades interesting so an
ID three was played first trying to stop
this Bishop b2 idea and probably a
blunder some yeah I think this is a
blunder definitely Caleb should have
played Bishop b2 takes rook b2 and he
has full compensation dues two rooks are
monstrous he might be even just better
here and in any case if he feels
frightened he can take and just take the
draw now he played rugby 5 thinking he
has oceans of time he can do anything
but here John played the killer move
rook h2 which is very good because
suddenly because for the moment it seems
that white can do anything really useful
maybe Caleb was thinking Oh Ruby 1 then
I have this nasty little trick in haha
I'll beat you but John came up with this
sneaky little rook lift rook h2 saying
ha I'm gonna exchange your best piece
and now it's going to be a race c2 now
either
Jonathan will run out of time and won't
have the defense against Bishop c3
checkmate ideas or he'll just come back
collect this pawn and collect the game
and notice that Caleb is under 2 minutes
right
so Jonathan just played Bishop f4 f6 and
I think this is the game for Jonathan to
win what a game man you couldn't have
asked for more back and forth yeah and
this is just gamble 1 this is just game
1 and it's super exciting
but let me ask the chat what do you
think and please use an engine do you
think white is going to win or not but
you said please use an engine yeah sure
why not I mean you're the chat you're
the viewer you can use an engine if you
want to okay so what's your pick who's
gonna win this game
pardon me Danny I'm gonna turn on my
engine here mmm oh don't tell me no okay
okay don't tell me I don't want to know
I don't want to know everyone turn your
engines one two three go
turn on your engines and send your
messages I gotta be honest I don't know
where the engine eval huh
honestly I think the best way to play it
for white is Bishop d2 and Bishop c3 and
trying to exchange this Bishop Bishop c1
is ill-advised guys check Nathan gets on
a good idea but I think Jonathan is
either a newborn machine or he's just
reading my mind he actually played
Bishop d2 try give full props ooh
because the idea is to go c3 Bishop b2
and if you manage to exchange that
Bishop off your dead winning ship D to
e5 oh you're jumping back but I'm sure
this was played Bishop d2 e 5 and props
for Caleb he's fighting fighting like a
lion he's trying to distract Jonathan
from achieving that goal so how's our
chat doing oh the chance doing great
everyone's having a good time
yeaow tchau tchau tchau tchau
yeah he says no engine Jonathan even if
no engine Jonathan even if evil is equal
psychologically Caleb may be in trouble
no he has a lot of faith in Jonathan
I agree that's a good observation Taco
Bell at 6 I would read your message but
I'm not really sure what it means or how
to pronounce that
name not a big enough okay nerd
apologies Kyle nice pics pat buchanan
Wow
Thank You Kyle so bishop see three of us
played and caleb is under a minute I
have to tell you this is gonna be a
tough tough match
well is he under a minute or under two
minutes Oh Rock is okay the doc just
updated Wow
yeah okay this is gonna we might we're
gonna have to see Caleb making some
quick decisions here
remember there's only a five-second
delay at this stage so I'm not saying
that it's easy to play this with white
but I have that feeling that this should
be objectively very nice hmm okay nice
shot nice Thanks kudos to the cameraman
on this one and you can see just if we
look at Caleb look at those hands buried
buried just burying his face hoping for
a miracle to happen not sure it will if
Caleb loses this I think this is gonna
hurt him psychologically be demoralizing
yeah but so far Jonathan been doing
great
he's been the king king of the hill man
calling someone a king and chess that's
that's anyone I know
nobody does that I see some nerves oh
look just look how that rook was posted
on g5 a confident person wouldn't post a
rope on g5 [ __ ] on f5 g5 and on a
little bit on h5 as well oh and he's
going back great defense
great defense by Jonathan
I have to give it to Jonathan he's been
killing this game I mean is is that
black have an idea of maybe pushing the
epoch he's he's only trying for a trick
of bishops eats me right now okay
but that's like a nose it's like a non
threat and look look at kale I mean look
at Jonathan he's not afraid of ghosts
he's like a Ghostbuster mm-hmm and if he
somehow extra Kate's his king from that
corner he'll be winning easy but he
needs to do that
mmm I don't like that move that much but
if it's with the idea of walking the
King to the center with King be one king
see to look and he's making space for
his King moves so that's gonna be
awesome
now oh oh oh my god what's wrong what's
wrong Caleb is almost under 20 seconds
yes oh man III and he's doing it and
he's doing it now I'm not sure that he's
going to win this game but it's Jonathan
for the win and he feels it you can't
feel the tension in the air
mm-hmm and that that room is dead silent
right now besides that clock yeah the
players hitting that clock you got Sam
and you've got the players in there and
he's got 30 minutes against 18 seconds
Oh what would be your odds here if you
wouldn't have a bet I don't even know
someone called Mike comer all right come
on one look all night come a room make a
call to Vegas and see what their odds
are king c2 that's a bit too too slow
but is he still winning this is Jonathan
for the win Jonathan for the win
what are engine people saying well the
engine itself says plus 1.2 right yes
this is solely winning yeah but to be
honest
Caleb will have play on the kingside
that those connected three pawns but if
Jonathan realizes that he should win the
a seven pond he'll be crushing this game
just crushing it yes and he feels it oh
yeah rookie seven was a little bit off
but it's okay just go after that pawn
play eight four oh and he missed and he
hung his Knight and he didn't take his
Knight Wow oh my god the nerds
Brooke c4 was on what it was a gift it
was a gift
refused where is that rook headed oh my
god it's rook c5 just defend the knight
defend anna defend the night what does
he have to do oh there we go
if end the night okay come on come
closer to that a5 pawn just push it push
that a pond come on you can do it don't
think just it's not about thinking it's
about winning a 4 a 4 it must be the
winning move you saying a 4 for white
for white yeah so okay King gauge seven
will be played but King f8 that was a
make mistake take the pawn take just
take the pawn with the knight don't
exchange the rooks good man
jonathan is a god it's god of chess time
so let's say that in front of him we'll
never hear the end of it 9 don't ever
tell him I said that deny it I mean just
check and go behind the pawn this is the
end of it caleb is going down caleb is
going down oh my goodness I mean its
history in the making
Ben who could have thought that this
would happen
84 I'm not sure about that one rook h5
rook age 5 the rug belongs behind that
pawn at least that pawn age 3 he has
that 5 second
no nine seconds against a whole two
minutes and Jonathan the hands of God
reaching and there's nothing nothing
that Caleb could do here it's over he's
on the floor he's rolling what will
happen next man what will happen it
could be lights out here for Caleb King
see five very how many blunders this is
gonna take for though to reverse I mean
we've seen this back and forth in the
seven seconds six five four
and he played g5 like he's not losing
Wow how is he doing that can the check
hold his breath how can they do that 85
that bond is marching and notice that
the a 3 square is blocked the night and
he flagged and he flagged oh casually
points that out and Jonathan for the win
Wow Jonathan Jonathan schranz draws
first blood in all in he is leading the
match two points to nothing and this is
big a win in the rapid Steelers they
believe it can believe it no I mean
Caleb and Jonathan the hands of God
Tamsin our chess gods now all what can
you do if Jonathan plays like that we
have no hope Caleb is dumped for this is
a big deal Jonathan is leading the match
two-zip I remember four and a half is
the magic number to clinch the match we
have one more rapid game to go and then
we'll have four blitz games if necessary
the rapid or double wait I can't believe
this no and and a lot of people are
gonna have so much to say with this game
including our correspondent Dennis LaRue
and I was talking with Dennis earlier
today and he was very excited about this
match and I understand that we have
Dennis ready to go he's gonna be giving
his insights Dennis if you're ready to
take it away okay thanks
guys what a an exciting day of chess now
take a look I have something really
interesting I want to show you
he's pretty innocuous right but actually
White's threatening to play e5 it's ok
blacks no slouch he sees the threat and
counters it by playing he fight himself
yet white is relentless attacking a 5
with the knight black defense with his
knight
and stronger games but in this game d6
was played to which the amazing response
d4 was played how can black even want to
continue here
maybe Bishop g4
no no or whites essence huh no ah
white says that's a dumb idea Bishop g4
is so stupid and I will show you the
line but I know all our viewers at home
can see it calculate it easily without
me having to move the pieces that after
de Queen da King D 895 wins the pawn
black sees this refuses to fall for
white Strix
and white says I'm gonna check meet you
buddy black says no I like to develop
and stop checkmates White says I'm gonna
redouble the attack on f7 with Queen b3
looks like Blackston quite a pickle here
wouldn't you say Queen d7 won't do it so
he plays Queen e7 threatening to play
Queen b4 check if BB 7 comes on the
board trading off the Queen's and taking
the steam out of whites attack white of
course just plays normal chess starts
developing black plays c6 to keep that
night off a d5 and b5
the golden rules are being followed
folks this is exciting stuff this is
exciting stuff which side will White
Castle on nobody knows
is really annoying so he tries to get
rid of it
but does white have a surprise for him
as Jonathan sharks like to say
I'll take those ponds
and get a winning unstoppable attack
what do you have to say about that black
pieces knocking d8 because castles long
leads into a quick forced win for white
and the rest just explains itself
doesn't it folks I'm attacking your PIN
piece you have to defend it and my
position so strong and so few of your
pieces are in play that I can just
sacrifice all my stuff just throw it
away and check meet you but what have
you try and trade off my strongest
attacking piece will I fall for it and
take here no sir no back to you guys in
the studio
Thank You Dennis nice insight from the
former corner man of one of our
competitors Caleb ben b who is now down
zero to two against Jonathan Krantz
after game number one my name is Ben
Simon
he's Grandmaster Denis barouche and we
are here for the most anticipated
expert-level chess match in history
Jonathan Krantz vs. Caleb Denby where
Jonathan leads to nothing now we still
have one more rapid game and then we'll
have four blitz games the rapid game is
25 minutes with a five-second delay it's
worth 2 points and caleb is going to
want to come back and win this one so he
can start fresh in the blitz we have a
dramatic dramatic for his game and I
have to I have to give it to Jonathan it
started out it all started thinking that
f3 will be the meme of the day but it
turns out Jonathan knew what's going to
happen you knew it all and it's it seems
that it's on Caleb it's Caleb to watch
that mean away because this was just an
amazing performance
like really really top-notch performance
by Jonathan Wright do you think Caleb
can make a comeback I think he can I
think he can remember he was three and
one favorite in this match so he's got
to remember that he he knows he can tie
this up and I think that this is still
gonna be a close match I'm not surprised
that a player won the first round and
look when you're gonna be 2-0 you know
so it looks like a big factor but it's I
don't think it is yet now if shruts wins
again I mean the match is basically over
all he has to do is get a draw in the
blitz stage so yeah Caleb definitely
does not he cannot let shruts win this
game to cannot and look at this
Denby has played c4 to start the round
so it's the English and we might just
look at the board here to start while I
get the digital board going so c4 Knight
f6 has been played
there we go hey chief
so it's the classical English variation
this g3 move now this was known to be
dumb because of c6 Bishop g2 d5 played
by Fisher against Petrossian but since
that people realize it nah not a problem
so Jonathan doesn't even bother with
that he's going the nimzo-indian way and
goes a 65 and now in Catalan waters
already and it seems like a heavy
theoretical struggle again just like in
the first game
our players are super super prepared as
we can see now Caleb could have chosen
to transpose into the main lines of the
Catalan the d4 and just get into the
openings that is heavily played by
Carlsen and vastly so but instead
chooses b3 now this b3 move is actually
amazing this was played by Kasparov
against Karpov when he had to win the
game so Caleb knows his history I'm sure
he knows that if Kasparov can palabra
went from this line so can I which-which
a match was that I know they played five
oh it was the return match where
Kasparov needed to score a win with
white 85 yes okay and it was a very
close encounter which ended up with
Kasparov winning it and the rest is in
history books and also in the history
books is this match so far Jonathan
showed amazing skills refused to draw
just ran out flat-out refused the draw
and then for the full point
and in fact caleb was trying too hard to
be Jonathan and instead of trying to
have full compensation missed a move and
was totally outplayed by jonathan so far
they're following theory they're in
mainline theory and i see that both
players are on autopilot they're kind of
rushing through their moves and as we
encourage you all to join us in our
YouTube chat exclusively on youtube this
afternoon Taco Bell at 6:00 says no one
is acknowledging Caleb's strength yet
but Caleb has just spent the last three
years training under the basement Hermit
Dennis LaRue one of the three legendary
chess players of st. Louis as far as our
videos go yes Caleb will show us all his
growth this game so Taco Bell has a lot
of confidence in Caleb
so there is confidence in Caleb I
concede in the chat yeah and the good
thing about this you notice the players
they the colors are on the same side
we're seeing us from whites perspective
here huh and the players get up in a
switch signs which means that for our
camera angles we're gonna get a good mix
of seeing the players faces so that's a
good thing so we're still in theory d4
is the classical way of playing takes
takes these to be and actually that's
the line that was played the other line
is b6 and often black goes Bishop e7 and
it's a long long theoretical struggle
now instead Jonathan goes for the main
line d4 takes takes takes takes rook e1
and we're going to see a reversed benoni
there jonathan is actually playing white
with a tempo down have you ever played
openings a tempo down yeah like every
single game and we
I'm 1,500 Bosh okay but sometimes I also
play a tempo down but it's alright and
Debbie actually has a good point here
even though he's playing the benoni with
white the fact that Jonathan is a tempo
down makes this whole line interesting
and Caleb might get an advantage here
also look at the times caleb has a three
minute advantage mm-hmm which might
actually be a problem for him later on
because as we noticed jonathan is a
blitz expert he's way better than Caleb
in blitz if you remember he's a hundred
points higher in blitz ratings well
maybe he should just let all the time
just drip off the clock yeah and yeah
well now I'm like superhuman how's that
work it's like The Incredible Hulk in
chess version so who says in shed that
Jonathan has this game in the pocket who
dares call it an already a game for
Jonathan well I don't know that anyone's
are doing that but Lawrence who says
that Jonathan is flexing at the board
which is something that he does very
intimidated you know have Lawrence plate
I don't know if Lawrence is here I think
at the club right now and he said if not
in st. Louis but I I don't know if
they've played I played a beautiful game
with Jonathan it was it was a loss
during the staff tournament that Caleb
won actually back in January Jonathan
and I played in the third round and I
was I lost I lost but it was a beautiful
game and it's one that I was telling
people I gotta show you this game
because it's if I was teaching my
greatest losses on YouTube I would show
that one because although the eval later
said that I was never winning it was
just pretty combinations
used in that game there's a nice little
nice little game Jonathan is using
high-class theory here
Bishop f8 and as we seen and maybe
Lawrence was kind of claiming that on
developing the piece here
yeah I'm developing but preparing the
idea of let's say if white just play
something random he can gain space for
the e5 and now black would be just
better okay so he's undeveloped in to
later on gain some space so for a good
reason now then Caleb plays Knight e5 to
stop to stop Jonathan from untangling
himself Knight takes e5 165 and you
believe it or not actually played this
with black he's following my theory he's
a good person he must be a good person
if he's following my theory actually
played Bishop d6 against Gawain Jones
with black and then happened boom Bishop
takes d4 takes takes and actually it was
like a long fight between me and go
Vayne and sadly I didn't draw the game
at the last moment even though I had
some drawing chances and the drawing
move but in the end
Jones prevailed so and he actually
played Bishop d6 will be see really see
them following the expert in this
opening we see that Jonathan is
following the expert but did Caleb study
this enough to know that Jones played
Bishop takes d4 here what do you think
that I see I don't know how much Caleb
actually prepped for this match you
would think that he sat down at a
computer and looked at some of the games
that he's played with Jonathan I
actually don't know he didn't and he
didn't play it ashamed that's why you
study my games and at least John Gavin
Jones's games so he played rook e1 not
knowing that Bishop takes d4 is an
interesting
here rookie one but look at look at
Caleb like he's all in in killer mode
he's out there he's trying to win at all
costs for him have you seen him have you
seen him
pissed at all cuz I think he is
hey he's on the comeback for sure I
think he looks as pissed as he can be
right well he just did a hair flip I
don't know if you saw that about a
minute ago I think that means
passive-aggressive thing I could never
see aa passive but no no no that's just
flat aggression aggression yeah yeah I
think Caleb means business in this one I
mean he doesn't want to come in and lose
to Jonathan I mean it really is for both
players I mean so much on the line I
turned I just cried and re to interject
but if you've seen I think Jonathan just
saw that hair flip and now he's like
anxious look at those sinking down
sinking down moments he's he's like
scared now but what is what is Caleb up
to what does he want to do why is he
bringing all his pieces back to the
second leg are we still in theory here
um probably Brooke even is not theory
anymore 93 he's trying to reroute his
night to see to still I consider a five
and ninety two and let's say like Queen
c7 h3 Bishop f5 this is a very
comfortable position as Jonathan will
prepare efore ideas later on first off
obviously he will go rook the 8th d1
Bishop c5 and it's an important moment
playing e4 and this looks very nice for
black obviously I played it the ideal
way for black but if he manages to break
through in the center this
should be really pleasant for Jonathan
so night III he played rugby eight
that's the other way to play this now
might be five might seem interesting but
in fact there's Bishop c5 now just chase
you've been a six
oh let me put that phone back and to be
honest with you this looks fairly
comfortable with Jonathan and you can
see those hard-earned hours paying off
or Jonathan why did you hesitate there
on the a6 well I didn't hesitate too
much
the fact is it's white to move so a6 so
I'd be hesitant to move if it's White's
turn right that's all yeah might get
penalized for that I might even get been
oh yeah maybe you know Sam's wicked I'm
very he then would find us in a
heartbeat oh yeah he'll throw the book
at you and those feed that rule books if
you've seen them they're really heavy
well the USCF they which were broad were
going by today is not too is heavy as
well you know first it's you know the
first time I met Sam I think he was 16
years old he had just become an arbiter
and he was running the tournament
upstairs and I it was like a Saturday or
something I came into the club and I
forgot there was a tournament upstairs
hmm and it wasn't one where you had to
turn in your cell phone there wasn't
like a security guard and you think so I
just opened the door and went on
upstairs and I was like oh like I I
don't know I was like talking to myself
or something you didn't expect say no
and sam dreamy right at the top of those
stairs and he said you need to leave and
I was like I've been working here for
years I don't I don't know this guy is
DNR but I was like all right I went
quietly rules are the rules
he is a rules-based person he doesn't
care who you are he would throw garry
kasparov out of the tournament hall if
he was making a noise Gary may not leave
but he could try but he would try HIPAA
try
actually night c2 was played and b5 and
that's a bit that's on the brave side
because that's basically sacrificing in
exchange the bishop c6 cuz I double
attack both of those rooks
yeah Bishop d7 thanks thanks now I've
said this before
rooks are overrated yeah yeah well tell
me cuz they don't do nothing they're
just chillin until they get an open file
so here that these two rooks being just
lame ducks you'd see that this bishop
will either hit on this d3 pawn or just
go let's say Queen d2 Queen a8 we can
get ready for this Bishop c6
and this these bishops would be just
killing white mm-hmm and maybe black is
not better but he has full compensation
as these bishops are working full time
in this position while these rooks are
well they show up to work but they're
like really nearly doing nothing really
okay so that's not the light position
that's not the light position but it'd
be cool if they get this one in fact we
can get here because Jonathan the Hulk
played b5 and there is a good chance
that we'll get there actually he played
Bishop d7 I actually disapprove of this
I would have liked to see Brooke b5
played Bishop d7 because this is way
more entertaining than the move played
this might actually be quite bad because
if Caleb is on the stingy side and I
don't know is he a stingy person chess
wise chess wise yes
I don't know well it turns out he is you
think he he collected the pond and he
sticks to it played a four so the Caleb
Caleb truck is on the roll yeah let's
see if that a four actually happens so
if your Joe if you're just joining us by
the way of a lot of people in the chat
saying what is this this is the most
anticipated strongest expert level chess
match of all time this is all in
Jonathan vs. Caleb and yes Jonathan
wants you to remember there's a reason
he gets top billing even though he's not
the highest rated he told us he wanted
top billing so that's what happened we
got to rapid games we're on game number
two of two rapid games then we have four
blitz games coming your way
after this following a short break each
game in the rapid part is worth two
points each game in the blitz is worth
one point and the first two four and a
half clinches the match and we have
Caleb and Jonathan to YouTube chess
celebrities here at the st. Louis chess
club on the YouTube channel both have
taught lots of classes Jonathan had a
very successful franchise called chess
openings explained which still exists
but he doesn't teach it any longer
and Caleb Denby teaches a class every
Wednesday night you can see now
currently these teach in the class is
called road to 2000
he's over 2,000 and once you get you on
the road to 2,000 so there you go there
and welcome fair enough
and let's be fair with Jonathan he won
the first game like the god of chess and
he Mina fide his opponent totally
it seemed that did you say Mima fight
yes I said he mean if I'd like it seemed
that did you invent that I certainly did
okay it's my invention
don't take it me me fight is mine I have
copyrights or whatever so anyways
Caleb seemed to be attacking trying to
be Jonathan but Jonathan struck back
okay any destroyed just destroyed Caleb
yeah no it was it was a crazy game
I mean you you had we thought I was
gonna win black was gonna win I was
gonna win
hey Jonathan gets the two points big
news caleb is really far down on time
even with the five-second delay he lets
his flag fall and in the game was
Jonathan's yeah and I'm hoping we're
going to see a replay soon enough
because that was a beautiful moment
anyways coming back to the game now
caleb is in fight mode and he's going in
for this game for the win now shrunk is
a pond on down and he played a six
trying to gain that pawn back and Caleb
did something I don't understand if
you're up upon you should keep being off
the pond it's just think the pond okay
he would take on b3 but Bishop a3 and
that a pond is heading towards queening
and I support there that's a bungee -
and that Bishop is just a great help
there and even if things go bad to worse
you can't believe it should be seven and
laugh at your opponent instead of
laughing at his opponent he played
ninety to me and that just loses the
pawn back which I'm not sure is a great
idea actually a takes B five would have
been really good here but instead
Jonathan fell for the dirty trick set by
Caleb he took on a380 takes b5 Bishop d6
and have you heard this thing that is
kind of the big news in chess that
Bishop bear is worth upon no I mean look
you got it you've got to put some
qualifiers on that one you can't just
say to a bishop pair is worth a pawn I
mean maybe a bishop error is worth a
pawn that has the potential of queening
right away and what are you talking
about elegant starting ring I'm talking
about maybe Caleb saw that hmm if I
could get the bishop there I'm willing
to give my pawn back
you think that was his way of thinking
or this is just another call for a mean
yeah maybe that ladder actually takes
takes a takes b5 Bishop d6 and I thought
that this is just beautiful beautiful
beautiful for Caleb but Caleb I think
just missed this hammer shot ever shot
that's not a thing so he missed this
hammer blow Bishop g4 double attacking
the bishop and the Queen and I think
slowly but surely Caleb will be under
pressure in this match Ben what do you
think well I mean Caleb's on the defense
as white we might be seeing the
practical end of this match faster than
we thought so how's the chip handling
this huge huge turn of events SNP Murray
says I'm still digesting rooks are
overrated I know what you mean there by
the michael truth you know one man's
opinion it might be fact sink chronium
24 asks is allama Caleb or Jonathan and
the LA milord is Caleb Caleb yes yeah
jonathan is vampire chicken online and
SNP murray also is puzzled he says the
bishop pair equals a pawn equals an
overrated rook am I in the twilight zone
you might be might be yeah welcome we
never thought we would make it downs
buggy who is the fellow on the right
well that is Grandmaster Dennis Boros
and I don't blame you for not knowing if
you just joined us because our chat had
an old description I have since updated
that reload the page and his name is
there thank you for joining us
so so far so good f3 and even though we
love bishops bishops are loved Fisher
loved it
so we must love it as well it's like the
law it's like the law of chess but if
for a pawn he gives it away so Bishop
takes f3 Queen takes Queen takes d6 and
let's do our tradition of counting pawns
hmm a 1 a 2 a 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 6 black is
up upon but it looks like white is
making a run for it on the a file that's
his only hope is to bank on that
a5 form if you haven't noticed this pawn
is trying to reach Queen land but it'll
be a long journey
in fact Jonathan is down on time but
he's a pawn help this could be game set
and match
if practically not officially they're
gonna play at least one blitz game even
if this is essentially but Jonathan the
chess God could pull it off
mm-hmm any think he's gonna make it the
Queen 'land well I don't think that pawn
will be Queen Land assures you're too
distant yes Queen land is a beautiful
place that'll never happen in fact if
you're familiar with benoni ideas you
might notice there's pawn sacrifice
efore he takes e4 and before efore this
bishop was a monster and it might even
help this pawn to Queen Mab and after e4
d take c4 we can safely call this bishop
up all because it does nothing it only
protects the c4 pawn which is not a
useful thing for a bishop now I know
everyone's playing
tactics time as we know la rue teaches
us that but if we learn positional chess
there would be like to have this night
post it on that's at the moment on f6
where would we like to have it posted
yes we just created that square for our
little pony
see 3 or III sees me or III or we have
an even closer outpost what does the
chat think where could we pose that a
little bit of pony might have to wait a
few moments to find out because I think
that we are on about a 25 second delay
so in each case I feel that Jonathan has
the advantage definitely he is in for
the run for the full point and if he
will find this efore idea later on or at
all he might just cash in any ideas
where this Pony is headed could we see
three could be see three it'll take a
journey but where else could be posed
that night Jacob plays and Marius funk
say 'if i yes 'if five if you put that
knight on e5 it'll do a great job there
for one white they'll have to watch out
and play some bad Queen move but if
they're not careful hello hello fork
land that's not a pleasant place -
that's not a pleasant place to be I
don't even the end of it yeah and even
if what Mike would find this then d3
comes and it's all blacks game and that
a pawn that you can notice it's not
supported anymore of at the bishop and
it is gonna be Jonathan all the way if
he gets this efore idea let's see what
he played turns out he played rookie
seven which is fine the idea is if a six
is played he will block it
now if you're white here you might want
to push that pawn just to divert the
attention of that rook and attack this
ePHI pawn if he can see Caleb you can
see that he's in some sort of pain
because he's at down the pond
and this might be the crucial game right
then it's ink he's extremely crucial I
mean this is not a 12-game classical
match with it I mean this is gonna
determine essentially a big handicap
potentially going into the Blitz round
so if he would let's say he would lose
this game how much he has to score it to
even up if Caleb loses this game
Jonathan will be up for match point
because each of the rapid games are
double weighted two points so that means
to win the match Caleb would first have
to force a playoff
he'd have to win four blitz games in a
row and then by the luck of the draw the
other has white or black in the
Armageddon playoff and then he have to
win that it's so uphill minuscule
chances if Caleb loses this rapid game
you don't believe and actually you have
a point there because as we said before
like three four times already
Caleb is a hundred points below Jonathan
and blitz rating in u.s. chess rating
yes yes ma'am and I'm not saying it
would be a done deal but uh that would
heavily favor Jonathan because as we
know he's the blitz god the god of chess
the mean king probably it'll take some
time for him to win this and it's not
over yet let's not kid ourselves this is
not over
caleb is still in this game it's not
impossible to find counter play and even
win this the question is if Jonathan
will find the right path in this
position hmm what do you think Ben will
we see 2-0 here for the sake of the
match I hope not honestly but it's yeah
I agree with you over in our chat we
have some fans a Jan Antony loves us so
much he wants to know who made us the
announcers
probably so he can send a thank-you
letter that is awesome
sync chronium 24 the meme king LOL you
have a fan dinner and also joke house 17
dennis is the man
ben is amazing as well man I mean I made
paraphrase some of that but thank you
very much if you appreciate it later on
we will have another Dennis LaRue corner
segment for you he's working hard out
there looking at these games very
closely so he can bring you his insights
later on and he might be out for revenge
because he was kicked out by caleb
wright well he says he's not and you
know what it don't believe these people
his job here is quite secure as a part
of our team is a correspondent who
wouldn't want to be a correspondent for
the st. louis chess club youtube channel
it's a lot of fun so any other moves
played since we went on that tangent yes
let us see i'm waiting for this machine
to load up but i'll have to give it to
caleb he found one of the best chances
in the position and he's trying to
paralyze Jonathan's pieces as i told you
before
efore would have been a strong idea and
Caleb took little time to figure out
that no I'm gonna play Queen c6 here and
no more e-force for you my friend and
just to preface what's the idea now he's
planning to go a six a seven which is
way stronger now without the Queen's as
there are less locators also e4 is not
as strong as before because it does
absolutely nothing this D takes c4 and
the bishop is not caged in on g2 but on
c6 helping his brother to Queen mmm
brother a pawn now so e4 is pretty bad
here
in fact here i think caleb is fighting
back he's getting good fighting chances
here because this exchange well he can
go Queen before but that can be really
dangerous with a six and a seven coming
also notice you can't move your rook
because I take on a five and now it's
already completely winning for white so
from a much much better position for
Jonathan turned into a slugfest with
Caleb having really good punter chances
so you're pretty certain at this point
that the Queen's are coming off the
board it's very likely it's going to
come down to a queenless middle game and
as I said before that rooks are
overrated let's say Knight g4 if he
would be planning to go to e3 a six
bouquet seven would you truly say that
rook on a seven is worth more than a
piece I in this case no no that rook is
a piece of pomp in on a seven that rook
should never be on a seven that's just
terrible and if we want to create a
prisoner in a seven we can just go
Bishop e7 and laugh at our opponents not
when Sam is watching you but laugh when
he's not looking
I think he's always looking he's always
looking here Dan yet so don't laugh if
Sam is around because he's a pretty
harsh
barb in ER I would know Sam choy ket
chief and sole arbiter for this event we
have yet to see him on camera but he is
up there in the world-famous boardroom
yet the tournament hall the st. Louis
chess club just two floors above us it's
where these two are playing in isolation
and he plays Queen d8
he's not following my advice but maybe
he's right
although I to be concerned and if he
would have a close-up on Jonathan I
think he's concerned as well mm-hmm
because Queen land is about to hey if
there is their Sam shortcut and he
doesn't even realize he's being watched
well you know what he's doing he is
making sure that the dgt relay is
running smoothly we got to thank him a
lot because without him we would not
have this digital board to put on the
screen for you so thank you very much
anyway back to the game yep so Queen D 8
was played and let's be honest I'm
always here for the mean moments oh it
couldn't tell you couldn't tell right so
a six heading towards Queen land that's
where we're heading to look II six and
if we are acting very pedestrian wise in
chess you say can I take on these six
takes takes a seven bouquet a takes
takes rook c1 and I play rook c8 and you
resign sacking the rook for the pawn
promotion very nice and I do this if I'd
like you know basic basic tactics but
you're here for fun mean moments and
that would be clean b7 now Oh is upon
unstoppable yeah thanks ah ah
so Queen b7 is take me I'm gonna clean
anyways so this is a perfect me moment
you take because you have to try it
a takes b7 now if you would try the good
old I'm going to go behind the pawn and
stop you then ha ha Luke a8 and then
there's no way you can stop me and I'm
also pinning your Queen and it's over so
you have to go back
rook a8 same thing Queen e7
takes you have to take with the Queen
and now which line do you prefer you do
you prefer the a line or the same line
then I like a you like a I like a well
that doesn't work that was the wrong
answer I tend to do that and to give the
wrong an but actually it's not that bad
actually
okay Vaughn it's fine but look see one
is more sadistic
so just because ninety seven you can go
rook c8 and not not just that you're
going to clean you're going to also take
the Queen on e8 now if you're watching
this and asking the question but what if
King f8 well you can move Bishop c6 and
you just win because as Ben would say
he's in full nelson
he wouldn't say full nelson ever don't
you ever say full nelson i mean i could
you could she's in a full nelson yeah
see he just did that I said it because
the knight can't move because if you'll
kiss goodbye to that Queen and if the
Queen takes the rook well I'm I'm a
conservative person and if we're heading
towards Queen Land
let's Queen and then it's over the
stakes and we take everything and
actually we're kind of looking for this
mini moment to happen but for that caleb
will have to play a six and also known
as the time both are head to head both
caleb has both of them have eight
minutes each I wonder who that does that
favor well I mean we were talking about
the different strengths and different
time can tells and you'd think that it
would have to benefit Jonathan the the
more we take down yeah but hey guys once
again if you want to follow these games
on a digital board online we have put
them on ly chess org and the link to the
study with these games is
now posted in our description for this
event so just reload the page and click
on that you could go to delete chess and
actually Caleb is going for it but I
just like the move he played because if
you have a bunny make the bunny run what
what do you see a Caleb would just like
put his head down yeah you know I don't
know why he didn't let that a pawn run
if you have a bunny make it run yeah so
probably Caleb doesn't own a bunny right
I would imagine he doesn't I don't even
I'm not even sure you've seen a live
bunny in his life he probably has even
though it's Easter somebody show him a
bunny he would know what to do then so
anyways he played Queen c5 which is a
bit too materialistic and I asked this
before I asked you Ben if Caleb is
materialistic and it turns out he is
because he wants too much on that e5
pawn as all good chess players are and
that's true but I mean less munching and
more cleaning would have happened after
a 687 mean c5 now I would pull the live
audience what percentages would you give
for a jonathan win here or a Caleb win
here to be honest I think it's 5050 at
the moment well about their composure
Joe Weider says Caleb is playing raw and
Jonathan is cold
yeah Jonathan plays calm chess just look
at him he's all calmed out just saying
I'm a pawn up it should be better no
risks I'm gonna pull it off our friend
Jacob Wilkins the computer chess expert
who we know quite well actually we were
we did the alpha0 show together
Jacob Wilkins had a very interesting
point he was on
the US chess website looking at the
histories for these players he says both
players have played relatively little
rated blitz so those ratings are pretty
useless for comparison it's a good point
to make and I kind of struggled to find
a good comparison between these players
I suppose the best is the u.s. chess
classical between these players even
though we're not playing like long
classical in this match maybe that's the
best to go by one only caleb has a
universal rating and then as far as
fidei I think Jonathan does not have a
feed a classical so it's tough to
compare these players by the numbers
they don't have all of the same the same
factors basically well you really don't
have to be a chess leap to compare this
to the boxing matches the legendary
jungle war was a jungle for the rumble
in the jungle war is like the the
off-brand the rumble in the jungle Don
King was there he said it's the jungle
war the children yes yes all right so
then yes could be compared this to the
that specific boxing match well over the
title as we all know this is also for
the title yes it was George Foreman the
heavyweight world champion coming in Ali
trying to regain a title he never lost
in the ring and Foreman had amazing
power but he punched himself out and
late in the match just really it was
quite sudden with Foreman completely
gassed out Holly caught him with a few
good punches and Foreman went down and
he couldn't get up so are you suggesting
that one of these players is in a firm
control but maybe they're going to gas
out so to speak on the board that's not
impossible yes in fact well full full on
might full-on fight mode just happened
and Jonathan did go E for okay it's
backing the punches there he goes but
I'm not
who's going to go down do you think
someone's gonna go down in this game I
have a feeling someone is you know what
I'm gonna make a call right now okay
there's not gonna be any draws match no
drawers no jaw not one no I'm not a
single - nope absolutely not
Aditya Chandra says 100% Caleb will win
Wow he's very confident in Caleb and the
Jacob Wilkins also a big boxing fan
apparently he remembers Ali and Frazier
the excitement in the Philippines ah
it's a real classic Jacob yes thank you
so actually it does feel that Jonathan
is backing the punches as he's chasing
this Queen away which has to move
somewhere to be four and ha I can read
Caleb's mind and see plain clean before
but now Jonathan will start to roll down
the Mississippi River with d3 d2 and I
don't know well Caleb
we will he be is still rolling with the
punches or will he just go down easy
there's some big foreign body blows
right there from Jonathan that look at
that thing coming down the board so
Queen B 494 and Jonathan is no easy
chess feat he goes and tries to post his
night on a three or a five and this
Knight g4 move is an a-plus name plus I
give it an A+ do chess players ever gave
an A+ yeah kind of well depending on the
individual player okay that night in A+
player for sure yeah that night is an A+
player it's actually a tricky move and
might get quite dangerous if that night
actually lands on e3 or e5 let's see so
Queen B for not g4 plate and let's look
at the x actually Caleb it has five
minutes while Jonathan has five as well
pretty even I mean remember both players
still have a five-second delay when we
get to the Blitz stage which is coming
up after this
after a short break we will have no
delay and no increment so it's gonna be
wild and crazy let's look at Caleb's
expression he does seem to be stressed
out no doubt yeah he's looking for a
while that's some man suffering that's
like a sad man's look don't you agree
all right well this is gonna be a lot of
crow tea you know I mean you saw the
interviews at the top of the show
Caleb super confident but for that
matter so was Jonathan but Caleb had a
little more of a cocky strut in the way
he talked and this might be a lesson
here for a 20 year old Caleb Denby yep
he might feel the pressure now I can see
it on his face that oh man oh man this
might get to 0-2 which would be 4 0
whether we change the poor 0 with this
with this control and system so Brooke
team on plate d3 this this looks like a
slugfest this looks very dangerous for
Caleb and and I think Jonathan is also
nervous but he's nervous in a good way
he's like excited he was like twitching
to play this game and he might actually
get a chance to play his opponent
meanwhile Kayla played this very good
move e5 opening up the bishop opening up
this bishop also preparing this a-six
a-seven ideas for the future now
everything is kind of under control for
black at the moment oh my god what's up
what happened Jonathan played a
fantastic sacrifice rook c4 I'm not sure
if it's
great but it's tactic for the ages
I I've not seen it Brooksie Oh at night
90 no so be thick c4 okay we have
tactics moments coming up which is a
loose specialty and now we can see why
Caleb should regret kicking him out of
his team because it's mate it's going to
be made on the board so obviously it's
Queen d4 check if King f1 Knight takes
h2 as the more elegant way of and they
it
but King G King h1 runs into our
favorite kind of checkmate yes mother
made smothered may my gravy Queen g1 oh
my good hand thank you for the game what
an amazing cap on this match well almost
that would be if Jonathan were to pull
that off yes but that's not is that's
not what's happened that's not what
happened
but rook c4 was still a brilliant spark
Queen these six very good idea broke d4
and Queen d6 was a good Savior I'm sure
that Caleb business Queen d6 idea but
the question is if that a6 pawn will
destroy Jonathan's dreams look at thee
for Queen takes the 8 Brooke the 8 a 6
and we'll go Caleb come back swinging
what do you think because that a 6-1 is
quite far far away and close to the
clean land will let the Queen well we
have a rook now on the seventh rank to
head off that pawn on a6 yeah that's
true
probably is going to be played I would
assume group the seven would be played
if that was if it was played I believe
played yeah I think we work t7 rook d7
Lavery 1960 with the 7 most played h3
and 986 now it might be that Calum is
coming back swinging so maybe maybe our
comparison of that Ali match was spot-on
yeah it could be that was pretty good
Bishop c6 played and Jonathan to use
some boxing lingo had him on the ropes
I have to tell you I was nervous for
Caleb there for a while because Jonathan
was owning this game owning this match
and also if he would have won this game
probably it would have been over
basically over yeah now Caleb is
capturing another pawn on b5 and
virtually even though Jonathan can still
have some fighting chance he has a deep
pond that could become dangerous it's
still a lot of pawns for Caleb who would
put money on Jonathan at this moment
live-chat what's your take on yes raise
your hands yes
so far in the chant a John Anthony
screams future of a pond is lost
well I wouldn't agree that a pond looks
to have a great future okay and a John
Anthony screams well the game is going
to end game well that's going to be an
end game it is an end game I don't know
why he's so irate okay
Michael and Pena asks who are Denby
entrants well might be a lost cause
Hey look at these guys they're blitzing
off moves on the board Oh Mayan Caleb's
shaking his head so detuvo splayed let
me back up a bit
d - so he's banking on the D - pawn rook
F 1 which is a little passive but okay
rook c5 Bishop c4 rook takes e5 rook f2
trying to gobble up that pawn well you
got key 1 check and recap 1 and he's
realizing caleb is realizing that he was
forced to go back now rooks was
exchanged here King takes f1 and now
it's getting tricky because that d2 pond
Jonathan does the reverse Ali the
reverse Ali yes they're very well known
can we get a closer look at the board
right now I kind of want to see where
we're at
I've played King F 2 so it's 2 minutes
against 2 minutes
well King f8 but this still looks very
dangerous for Jonathan and I'll answer
right now who these players are these
are two very well known YouTube
personalities and also staff members
longtime staff members here at the st.
Louis chess club Jonathan is gained his
fame as the instructor of chess openings
explained I ran for a couple of years
and Caleb Denby currently teaches road
to 2000 which you can see every
Wednesday evening most of the time it's
absolutely live here at the st. Louis
Chess Club YouTube channel and we can
see
johnathan musters all the tricks he has
but it's not enough against Caleb as
he's doing his job winning this game
quite easily as Caleb Wong that ever so
dangerous spawn on D to that idea of
contr attack comes to a halt and I think
this is the end my friends this is the
end as Jim Morrison would say you were
just a pop culture phenomenon well
everybody has to love some of their Jim
Morrison songs live coverage what's your
favorite J Morrison song that would
relate to this game f6 a big mistake
rookie too and that's it that's it and
Jonathan shows the signs of giving up he
gave that a little shrug there I thought
it was gonna stick his hand out and
shake hands those nonverbal signs shows
you that the player is giving up and I
think you're going to see the hand look
the six plates and disgust and you can
see him shaking his head internally
taking the rope takes he looks he takes
the bishop he's seven and the pawn
reaches Queen land they're doing Caleb
smiles as he deservedly wins this game
Boros we have ourselves a match these
players are tied 2-2 - Wow Wow that's a
lot of fun was it fun so here's what we
have upcoming we still have four blitz
games to play each one is worth one
point hey it's pretty simple to follow
from here on out but right now I
understand that Jonathan is being called
to a staff meeting that could be a big
factor when he resumes blitz because
Caleb's gonna have time to rest in
theory and Jonathan has to go to a staff
meeting and it will go until about 2:20
I understand which is when we'll come
back with more games I think we're going
to have Caleb down here for a post rapid
interview in the interim we can talk
about the amazing comeback and his
thoughts stirring the game but before we
do that
our correspondent Dennis LaRue is
standing by and let's take a look at
insight from Dennis Dennis take it away
hey thanks guys this is some exciting
chess Wow I am just a happy camper all
this chess I don't know what to do I am
beside myself anyway I want to talk to
you guys about a very interesting
position take a look at this what a
doozy oh my goodness how does white
proceed here is he winning is he losing
drawing nobody knows unless he finds the
amazing move rook to whatever square
that is
now the casual observer may say didn't
you just hang your rook on h6 and I'll
tell him take it and then I'll say
checkmate
back to you guys in the studio
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello we're back with a comeback bonus
it's uh really something not the way I
imagined it would go but so before we
talk about your comeback we have to talk
about the painful part of this fair
enough I'm ready to go through yet so so
f3 yes so the thing is mm-hmm at this
moment when he played f3 yeah did you
feel that this game will turn into me
into what into a meet I didn't I I
thought maybe I thought maybe I would
have a you know I would be reliving this
one for quite a while after you Knight
c3 so I don't know why I didn't just
play something simple I don't know why
you're not just 96 and then I can play
chess better than Jonathan and I should
win the game okay I guess there's a 97
that's kind of painful so you're not 96
996 not 96 but Knight f6 or something
yeah
but so I mean then g5 is coming and I
was I was quite nervous yeah yeah you've
seen the little nervous while having
this position yeah I mean fair enough
I've been checkmated before in the Cairo
so I kind of see recognized the warning
signs
what was the warning sign um I I you
know his pun appeared on g4 as it
usually does and then I didn't see
anything stopping him from going further
with just f4 and g5 and I was like um
I'm probably worse here yeah so I went
for this Knight c3 sacrifice and I
thought it looked very interesting I
wasn't sure exactly how Jonathan would
defense he played one of the lines I'd
calculated but I obviously missed some
things later on down the road so kind of
I wanted to ask you did you feel that
after rugby aids you look that Jonathan
and no I looked this guy in the face and
I said he's he's too scared he's he's
not gonna just play f3 and then he did
it wasn't a full bluff though I did
calculate a lot of the lines before I I
played rugby 8 but you know I knew I
could I could play something like 906 if
I had to and then I thought it actually
looks quite decent I wasn't sure how you
would stop just a Bishop b2 eventually
so after he played f3 mm-hmm were you
thinking oh my god I'm going to be
turned into me or oh my god I'm going to
turn jonathan into me no I wasn't
actually thinking either of those things
I was just thinking out you know it's
gonna be it's gonna be an interesting
game so I don't think much of memes
during you know that's for the preview
videos and the dentist's interviews at
Dennis LaRue so actually talking about
Dennis hmm you kicked him out of your
team yeah it's so creative differences I
think so I mean maybe is that that the
reason why you didn't play Knight c3
immediately Knight c3 immediately
interesting I was too afraid to the
frame uh yeah I thought he just takes it
so maybe you need Kneedler route back as
an encouragement because I'm sure he
would want Knights easy to be played but
what if white just takes it that that
could be a problem
then I'm done a piece that is true but
you take back and then you go Ruby I
thought a Queen c4 here
Oh Queen C form oh okay we need five
yeah just King a1 a1 okay probably
attack both Peter out okay I can see
that and no I mean I'm sorry yeah I mean
not even King a1 there's just a knight
c6 or something maybe just knight c6 and
I'm not convinced though ah I was in the
game yes there's like repeating it no no
King one you go King a 100 wait sorry it
will be a king a1
you can't go Bishop e3 you can but then
a do Knight takes Queen and there's
Knight B 3 and they they have this
sneaky sneaky backwards yeah or even
like if Knight b3 wasn't there Queen b3
years and that's
yeah that's but so this all look using
to me so I didn't want to play this way
okay
but I saw this interesting line that
happened in the game where you place
Queen c4 and I have the circ v8 move and
I thought it looked quite awkward for
white and I didn't really see what he
did you see bishop so you want
I saw a bishop see one of course and the
plan was work b2
I obviously was considering Bishop b2 as
well but I thought you know that would
be a draw right Bishop b2 would be a
draw no thanks
no no I'm sorry I meant instead of rook
B - oh okay but this should be - Bishop
b2 King Taejo yeah that would be a draw
oh yeah that's why I showed you him
that's kind of what I expected actually
cuz I thought Queens before I would have
some really decent chances yeah
Queen c4 actually we were kind of on the
same wavelength
okay saw that this is going to end in a
draw of it yeah b2 please see where I
was kind of surprised yeah I thought you
know okay maybe Rick b8 and there's
actually really something going that
would be it looks very nice Bishop back
where I was totally shocked the bishop
at home I was expecting actually a
bishop move I in my head I didn't really
discern the difference between III and
f4 but I thought okay maybe he moves
this Bishop to defend the pawn I'm not
sure how she actually defends rook e1
yeah so Bishop f4 takes takes I honestly
thought that he had full compensation my
yeah I I was actually feel I was happy
but unfortunately I you know I spent all
my time calculating these lines and
night d3 I couldn't find a way it's
actually five did you miss for cage - um
is this idea so I missed that I didn't
have I thought c2 would be winning after
no takes HT - originally good then uh be
a trick b5 I don't think was the best
square cuz I thought I should go to b6
instead maybe so I have a rug c6 option
mm-hmm
because b5 is just really outbreaks I
can't play with c5 ever which became
kind of a problem yeah I was even
considering why not Bishop b2 rook takes
b2
they should be - I thought King b1 can
be one that brave rookie - Bishop takes
b8 oh that's a problem
yeah that's kind of a problem yeah ah
okay so the King b1 interjection yeah
okay so yes probably you should have put
the real combi since I think Rick b6 and
I actually have very decent chances to
win yes Rick c6 is
it's gonna be a huge threat I'm not sure
how you would untangle yeah because as
you're mentioning take c2 and the house
of rook can actually go to c6 yeah and
so but even in the game line
I wasn't he found a very creative way to
get like untangle his pieces but I
couldn't see how he could move anything
which was yeah interesting so I wasn't
sure about this f65 plan I know that was
a really good plan I expected very good
I thought maybe if I played a five a
four I could kind of but if he does the
same thing and go we should lead to
bishops III see if I though there should
be five yep
a 400cc uh-huh and so now I'll play f6
okay I just might do Bishop b2 not not
be tunes so you thought might be okay I
was just I was only calculating too cuz
I'm gonna exchange it off and round up
the seats upon I think this yeah this is
even I don't know I mean Bishop d6 now
and then the point was that I would yeah
a3 and Bishop c3 there's really there's
nothing there's nothing there's nothing
I just round up the pawn and I went yeah
I mean this was all going this yeah no I
have left six I think was a very good
practical choice fair enough a5 yep here
before takes takes Knight be - yeah rook
g5 was probably not that good but maybe
you miss Bishop d2 s g5 um no I mean
what else do I play I have to start
taking puns I think cuz well I don't see
a way to maintain my see two pawns
yeah or maybe just come with your king
closer and then tried to go f5 cuz he'll
need some time anyways to entangle yeah
I'm just imagining if I could play
tricks c6 here how great my position
would be that is to regret the always
feel yeah yeah here and whatever he
played like chess God and yeah no you
played very very well touch yeah get out
of this I thought that endgame probably
I'm losing
right and yeah yeah it was especially
the King f8 move was very very bad by me
yeah but this as the some engines were
saying plus one so it should maybe be
drawn then no plus one is losing okay so
yeah King f8 was unfortunate but I'd say
that there's a like you have fighting
chances yeah I mean what if I just play
h5 here no that's a good idea I thought
I was dangerous I think save five h4 and
I'd see four I'm back h3 okay three okay
yeah yeah it's good I see I'm quick yeah
quick Dennis yeah you are
Dennis yes trained me but apparently I
wasn't quick enough
I needed here no probably yeah yeah h5
would have good drawing chances there
anyways well he had the comeback game
yes and I asked on air Ben if you're a
stingy person and he said no as far as I
remember and you've been collecting
funds let me wait were you expecting
Bishop d4 yes I was
I considered it you know I I just call
it a game for Bishop takes d4 I can't
quote a game actually it's my game its
your game sorry did you win that game no
I I did you were black thought I was
black well fantastic I should have
played it um no I felt bishop this
bishop f8 to DC I knew 98 is the main
line instead of eight right and so I
thought something must be really wrong
here but then you know I had done a
little bit of practice a little bit of
looking at just the musicians with E 5
so I went for something I was familiar
with because fresh off this loss where I
you know sacrificed a piece and bold
style and then so you felt that it's
like you know more I'm more comfortable
it's a rapid game I'll just play what I
know
by the way I've played d4 my whole life
uh-huh and then leading up to this match
I was hinting to everyone that I was
gonna play e4 so I was I was quite happy
with what I see for decision because
Jonathan was sneaky
for idea so 93 you're just doing this
routine and b5 takes what would have you
done if I take on b5 um yeah I was
actually planning to give up the light
squared Bishop rook I thought it would
be quite good other than that you know I
was also considering just night back to
a3 okay so you consider yourself being
better here I think so I think maybe I
can get in NF for like right away okay
and then take dangerous yeah
it's getting complicated I'm not saying
black is better I do I think that black
has compensation yeah definitely it's
not like a full exchange but you know I
I wasn't dead set on Bishop c6 I was
also planning maybe Knight 83 instead
yeah I'm just coming back to c4 yeah so
okay coming back to this one he's six
why didn't you take on a6 I was thinking
he would second exchange I was thinking
be a six Rick v3 mmm-hmm and Bishop a3
Bishop a38 know in my head I was just
calculating a seven and a five and I was
oh
Bishop a3 I guess I have to take okay
can I just play Rick take some corn high
five and round up that pawn Knight c4
but you know I you lose a four-hour
losing fire it's kind of petering out I
thought yeah well I can also defend it
look I take it yeah but it's still um
yeah this looks looks quite good for
white actually the line in the game
though I thought I also looked very very
nice sweet takes takes I assumed you
miss Bishop chief that was a yeah I I
played it so quickly and confidently and
it was just a feather as they would say
yeah I mean it's it I think the last
game actually got in my head a little
bit I was forcing myself to play with
some tempo play quickly but it's it's a
very simple tactic to miss here take any
you know if treason yeah and I think II
for would have been a little bit pain
I was expecting you for actually and I
was quite nervous about it because this
looks like really good either if I put
my knight here or d3
well yeah I mean I was planning to just
play e5 back and then uh and hope for
the best
yeah yeah this is dangerous for you you
know that's uh that's a I would say
above Jonathan's rating that that
sacrifice dogs being fires okay you know
needs a little bit more before he can
learns to sacrifice those in the air and
Ben was really really mad when he saw
Queen c5 yeah why is that you play a six
a six just Rick a seven but what is that
we're doing they're like you can't take
this just looks really nice for you yeah
if I take those rook be study six okay
okay I can see your point
okay well maybe you move the Queen now
and then if you tagged then you have
Bishop e7 uh Queen b6 maybe six I guess
you take it take on e5 - because you
can't take cuz I take on b8 interesting
yeah I can I consider this I was a bit
afraid of losing the phonic this looks a
bit better okay so clean c v e4 which is
a pretty good move here nigt this this
was a waste of time Knight g4 was well
he I Jonathan you know he did I don't
know if you're aware of this I was you
know looking at his his online profiles
to see what he was up to during the days
leading up to this mansions and
professional prep you know a couple
Sundays ago he did a thousand tactics
and whoa so I think Jonathan spotted
this Queen d4 nonsense from a long ways
coming and he's like I've got to do it
I'm gonna get him I think that's his
mindset but it's a 94 yeah that move
just looks terrible
probably d3 something oh yes d3 d5
I was planning to do something similar
yeah ii 5 and then uh i guess they're
playing Knight d7 but probably i can
even have this sneaky idea of d2
interesting just
yeah yes this is nothing just single
simple fun singing bones hanging and
after Knight g4 you did
classic rope-a-doping yes and it's just
over no guys there's not much left to do
so yeah made it a bit hard on myself
with that Bishop d6 move that it's it
was just I think was just crushing
before that but yeah it is a good
comeback and thank you for joining us
yeah no thank you for doing commentary
Thank You Dani Machuca for helping to
set this up Ben Simon for their offering
his time as well looking for the next
round
yeah thanks very much I look forward to
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back once
again to st. Louis for the most
anticipated the strongest expert-level
chess match of all time all in Jonathan
vs. Caleb where the match is tied two to
two and we will decide it in blitz my
name is Ben Simon and I'm joined by the
esteemed Grandmaster Dennis Borel we're
having a good time today yes this has
been a big fun yeah and before we get
started with our blitz rounds you know
the players are getting ready we want to
tell you you're pretty excited about
this upcoming exhibition at the world
chess Hall of Fame bar aren't you it's
MC Escher infinite variations and it
opens on Thursday May 2nd across the
street at the world chess Hall of Fame
yeah I mean it's been crazy this whole
match and if you love crazy you should
check out MC Escher because you know I
actually have this the stairwells that
way yeah infinite right
yeah the infinite stairway yeah but I
still love it it's actually an
interesting thing have you ever thought
about being in that stairwell if I'm in
the right state of mind yeah actually I
might have dreamt that I'm sure many
people dream that but you're stuck in
that stairwell and say hey I can never
get out of here well it's gonna be
really cool and it opens on Thursday May
2nd at the world chess Hall of Fame and
it runs through September so if you
can't make the opening which is always a
huge gala at the world chess Hall of
Fame be sure to come by st. Louis hey
come by one of the tournaments maybe the
Sinquefield Cup you can check out MC
Escher infinite variations at the world
chess Hall of Fame for more information
world chess HOF org well we'll come back
to that a little bit later on our great
sister organization the world chess Hall
of Fame let's get to the action we have
up to four blitz games to play let's see
how they're doing up there in the
tournament hall I understand that chief
arbiter Sam choy cut has the players oh
hey look at that they've taken off the
jacket so at least Jonathan has he's
ready he's showing the guns flexing at
the board as we say no sleeves no sleep
you can't have sleeves because remember
this is game in five with no delay with
no increment it's
that this game will be over in ten
minutes and they're doing the good
old-fashioned match strategy you choose
an opening you play our line and we're
back in the same caro-kann line that we
just discussed like 20 minutes ago with
Caleb and he does the league illegal
castling very well known to many people
that castling is super illegal I'm sorry
we actually had an illegal Castle yes
that's illegal counseling you can't
castle like that I totally missed it I
gotta be honest I believe this is very
famous since the match nopony achi nepo
Miyaichi
Nakamura where Nakamura Castle with this
two hand castle ink and it's not it's
frowned upon
I really can't be their rules yeah but
remember we are under us chess rules for
this event and I know that they differ
and I honestly cannot keep up with the
rule changes in that regard the
one-handed Castle versus the two-handed
Castle it seems like it changes every
year honestly and I know that a US chess
in the few day laws are not always
aligned in precise situations such as
these so it could have been legal well
probably that big question is and I'm
asking the live audience by USCF rules
is it legal to castle with both the
holding both the rook and the king at
the same time also we can see Jonathan
being in huge preparation already
putting mounting some pressure on Caleb
as Jonathan is flexing his muscles
playing really good chess with wide so
far and remember this match is tied 2-2
to the first player to get to four and a
half points clinches the match and no
more games will be played it will be
over now if they split this four-game
blitz series and the overall score is
four to four then we're gonna go
to a 5 minute versus 4 minute Armageddon
playoff winner take-all a draw will
count in blacks favor there must be a
winner f3
yeah way way way to solid I would like
to have four more
in fact caleb is insistent please lay up
for please please please and he does
caleb is doing fine but I'd still kind
of prefer Jonathan's position but
bouquet g1 made little to very little to
no sense I don't know why he played that
it really didn't do anything black is
doing fine but if anyone's better it
must be white a 5 B 3 this is going to
be a Karpov Ian game then what do you
mean by that
meaning a masterclass by somebody by
somebody somebody okay so far white
white is exhibiting the signs of doing
the master class it's not that it will
necessarily happen but there's a good
chance take for the a pond yes of course
you're trying to take towards the center
the only issue with black is the
structure look at all those palm islands
the a5 c6 and the rest of the ponds
meanwhile all of the pawns for white is
in big chunks g6 is the move that I
don't like on the same perp on the same
reason in the same principle now there
will be a potential weakness on h6 and
there is a famous saying by the recently
passed baretsky and also in many other
Russian chronicles you can learn you
need exactly - I mean two weaknesses to
win a game I've heard that yes right now
if you can count that how many
weaknesses does
in this position well he has week a pawn
won the C pawn is isolated yes that's -
and what we might have one more over on
the the H side here in just a moment
yep it was a three am i right yeah how
about that
so that would be way more than enough
and if you look at the times basically
Jonathan is up a whole minute and I
think if Jonathan plays his cards right
he should win this game I want to give a
shout out to Nick risco upstairs because
he is to my knowledge putting in the
moves on leach s org manually from this
he does not have the the direct link to
this board right here so thank you very
much it looks like he's keeping up with
it somehow the link to watch this game
by yourself is in our description of
this video and actually caleb is
defending better than how jonathan is
handling the situation because caleb is
trying to exchange off as many pieces as
possible therefore getting close to a
draw the main issue is for white that
without the rooks it's very hard to
create chances and it's a shame because
he should be close to crashing through
as we said three three weaknesses now
for that now the problem is caleb has
the big problem that the king is on f7
it cannot really move because the h6
spawn will fall the bishop on c7 is also
stuck because the e5 upon is a chronic
weakness now Jonathan has to find the
star move and the star move would be
somehow to break through with f5 or at
least somehow to create a little bit of
hole so his King can come
come through this should be six and this
is interesting well Jonathan just wants
to get into a position where he's
munching on pawns yes now he's also
trying to get the King back Bishop d2
that's interesting
now f5 would be an interesting idea
Bishop c5 very very karpova and slow
massaging going on f5 might be
interesting as well what he I think he's
repeating too much looks like we might
have a draw here you think but I don't
see a reason why he wouldn't try harder
why are you come on you better be for
Bishop c3 it's a draw and wrong
well I that was unexpected
on some level I mean the match is still
tied two and a half to two and a half
the first one to get to more points as
the winner we have three more blitz
games to go everyone and but it was a
regretful miss because he wasn't really
risking anything he needed to try and
mother open up the position with f5
creating more problems and just or at
least walk in with the king of through
e5 and tried to attack the c6 pawn
do you think that Jonathan realized that
do you think nerves got to him or do you
think he really just thought it was
straight-up draw there was nothing left
to press for I think Caleb did a nice
psychological trick on him because he
played confidently quickly like he knows
what he's doing when in fact he was in
big trouble
and even the end when they shook hands
it felt like caleb was forcing his will
on jonathan yes and he was tricked into
accepting the faith of a draw and
sometimes that does happen like he was
showing off that what are we doing here
this is going to be a draw bye
repetition anyways when in fact we had
good chances of winning well Gus
jennette in' in our chant has an
interesting take on it
he thinks Jonathan knows or knew he will
be smashed if he tried anything and
that's why the draw came about well
practically there's no chance being
crushed in that position so there's
nothing to lose there so he in these
positions with only bishops and Kings on
the boards you can try as much as you
like and you should because there's no
chance of losing a cosh in the chat says
Jonathan should have pushed there's no
increments
he had a slightly better position yeah I
think that might be the consensus around
here but we will see what happened we'll
see what happens later on I understand
that we do have our correspondent Dennis
LaRue standing by once again for another
edition from the street let's go to
Dennis LaRue in his corner thanks again
guys what a bunch of exciting games were
looking at today let's take a look at
this position again now some of the
viewers may have pointed out that black
have may have more than one option
besides g8 and today I have to say I
hope you guys are proud of yourselves
doctor you guys in the studio
Thank You Dennis interesting insight
there from the former cornermen of Kaleb
Denby that we saw him in the opening
shots with the chicken chase straight
out of Rocky - and they who knows maybe
down the line this will give Kaleb a
victory yeah it's very interesting
because Caleb oh hey look the player the
players their players are ready for
their fourth game we're all overall and
their second blitz game
let me open up our necks let's get a
shot of the board here I don't know if
we'll need this digital board but we'll
have it just in case we need it
and they are off they are off the
players of switch colors caleb has the
white pieces in this event and they're
following the same game they're playing
the same line she's interesting when
they're in big rush she's interesting
98 so as Caleb told me he was expecting
98 more and didn't play Voki eight this
time f6 rookie one five and it's all
mainline theory but as Jonathan takes a
pause it's going to be very interesting
here because whoever wins this will have
kind of a substantial lead well it's
getting more substantial as time goes on
right I mean each of these blitz games
is worth one point both players are at
two and a half you need to get to four
and a half to win outright
yeah and we will have a playoff if
necessary will be a winner-take-all
Armageddon if this thing is tied four to
four after the next three blitz games
this is one and then there's two more
blitz games after it and I don't know if
this is a blunder or a sacrifice but
it's interesting
the b7 pawn was on pre for a long long
time and now it's busted it's totally
busted for Caleb why already with the
nightly ending on c5 double of tanking
on b3 and d3
beautiful positional play by Jonathan
and unexplicable mistakes by Caleb not
taking on b7 while he still could this
is just terrible news and will he
survive I do not think so they that
night that Eagle soon to land on d3 will
just destroy and cause havoc and this is
a fairy chest but that Knight does have
wings I'll give me a dad Knight does
have wings absolutely and and that look
by Caleb it's the look of a sad man not
a Sandman a sad man he definitely knows
what it's like to be the sad man but I
think he has blue eyes I'm to look
behind them
did Jonathan Jonathan is rocking that
10-year anniversary single Louis chess
club shirt you know the st. Louis chest
girl she looks younger than that one
well with the well he was the same one
he was wearing last round we're just
seeing at the other side but yeah I mean
we celebrated the 10th anniversary of
the st. Louis chess club last July with
just a big all-day event
I mean the entire chest campus just had
activities it was nuts but yeah we all
got those cool t-shirts too and actually
Caleb gave a choice to Jonathan to take
on d3 or win the exchange and as you
would listen to me I would take the pawn
because that would have totally
destroyed the structure of Caleb's now
it's not that the position is not
totally winning for Jonathan but the
other one would have been cleaner also
let's look at the time Jonathan has a
full minute advantage and he is the true
blitz expert and it seems that it
actually works the quicker they get the
better Jonathan place compared to Caleb
well it's what we're seeing today and
Jonathan with the black pieces pressing
with an advantage a super super
important part of this match right here
and look at those nonverbals he is like
polishing his nails he's kind of feeling
the victory within his grasp
jon is feeling it
you're just a master of emotions at the
board aren't you well you have to learn
the nonverbals to be a good player at
least you experienced them sadly you
shouldn't but you do experience those
things now this looks magnificent for
Jonathan
so okay queen eight looks a little bit
weird but it's still very good for him
at least a defendant upon queen a4 going
very aggressive planning to plant the
Queen on b3 attacking the d3 pawn Oh but
Knight takes d4 sacrifice what is this
working this might not work because rook
takes b2 might actually and and I think
Queen takes e7 he might have missed the
bishop d5 counter tactic and he might
and he misses it bishop d5 and it's over
and suddenly kate for caleb caleb was
winning yes and oh oh look at that
another rope of joe by caleb he was on
defendant they're not even gonna shake
hands I mean and we don't have audio up
there I'm sure Jonathan verbally is
saying it is the game over it his game
is over it's checkmate on the board okay
there it is so a heartbreaking loss for
Jonathan and the biggest mistake was
always disgust him he's disgusted it was
he rushed he rushed too much even though
he could have been winning easily can
you show us all here on earth board can
we get our digital board up yeah I'd
like to see what we're talking about
even in this critical moment he could
have taken on d3 and it's easy win even
if it's just a pawn he took a critical
pawn on d3 and this position will
collapse he decided to give the Eagle
for that measly rook takes takes okay -
which is very nice and clean a8 is just
too artificial just play a normal move
play Queen d7 and just chill you're just
winning we've been eighth in the
problem is that the queen is offsides
Bishop b2 queen a4 Knight takes d4 and
as far as I could understand there was
this idea of rook takes me to here if
the Queen takes there's no more tricks
there's nothing to take on e7 anymore so
you have to take with the rook but then
I check you first you have to either
block with a queen or the bishop but if
you block with the bishop I take takes
and I take your rocket and this would
have been a win the bishop is not ready
to jump to d5
take six and he was way too focused on
winning some stuff but after Queen c2
tragedy struck
and Bishop d5 here mean takes a faith
and that was the end of it and Caleb
survived and even won yeah that was that
hey that's blitz you know what a crazy
turn of events but Jonathan deserves a
talk because he was doing great great
before the tragedy struck I think he
didn't use his time if he would have
used he's allocated extra two minutes he
would have won this game mm-hmm well
guys we have up to two games to go
remember in the next game if Caleb wins
the match is over because he stands at
three and a half points you need to get
to four and a half
Jonathan has only two and a half a
single game means so much at this point
in time and we saw Caleb just win with
the white pieces very unexpected this
white victory for him
but he's got to be feeling good what I'd
like to do now is we got to go to Dennis
LaRue with another segment from the
street it's Dennis LaRue's corner Dennis
take it away hey thanks guys things are
getting really intense up there I'm here
to help offer some insight just into
chess in general now many new to chess
or even experienced Club players are of
the opinion
that white is slightly better in the
starting position stock fish and many
other engines give us an evaluation of
white being up 0.2 roughly the value of
a quarter of one of these guys to them
all I have to say is take a look at this
line
where is your advantage and out light
back to you guys in the studio Thank You
Dennis I think that will do it so it is
three and a half points for Caleb Denby
two and a half for Jonathan trots and we
have potentially just one last blitz
game if Caleb can wrap it up but we have
two left in regulation the winner will
be the first player to get to four and a
half points and we have some comments
here on YouTube a person whose name is
in characters I cannot read says
Jonathan get Caleb you foolish little
man
okay that's an interesting changing of
someone's day okay Peter Sturm is
stunned he says Jonathan that bad a
cashes lmao and a John Anthony says haha
this is brutal poor Jonathan do you
think Caleb considers himself a true
genius well that's something we have to
ask Caleb mm right and thank you all for
joining us here in the YouTube chat we
will be reading your comments for the
duration a the players are in the board
room and they are ready for rapid number
three here we go
this is it Caleb if he in way with black
he will be the champion
so actually Jonathan surprised
Caleb slightly because instead of facing
a Catalan now he's facing the Catalan of
Jonathan's now it's all theory so far
and you're in main main theory which as
we know is a cup of tea of Jonathan's
because he is the big opening explained
expert
you know they seem to be struggling to
remember this very very theoretical line
which was actually played by none other
than Fabiano Khurana as he was facing
Dingley rounded the back black pieces
but it does seem that Kaleb might be out
of book here now this is a very very
sharp line as we can see Caleb gave away
his rook for a light piece which means
rooks are overrated well it's good that
he subscribes to that and actually a
blunder by as far as I can see is a
blunder by Caleb Bishop f4 yes and the
knight is dropping yes and this is
almost resigned a bull for Caleb we
should have five then now the killer
movie for counter-attacking the piece so
far so good for Jonathan it would be a
clutch performance right if he dies it
would be amazing I mean a what it would
a picture of a blade imagine a
winner-take-all blitz for the last blitz
game that's what we can be looking at
look into the eyes of Jonathan Franz
look how he's blazing for glory and
Caleb realized it he realized he messed
up big-time
that one-point advantage push out the
window and it's an open question who
will become the meme of the day Dennis
do you perform do you compete in a lot
of rated blitz games whether tournaments
or anything I do I do I occasionally
play in tournaments online tournaments
no but it's just online oh no I do play
at the board as well
could I enjoy it it's a lot of fun but I
think you can tell that they are bit new
to lit sound controls because you have
four minutes and you play a nervous
Bishop takes a seven you have four
minutes you have a lot of time there's
not enough time
it's just too much time to get nervous
give or do you play by the way I love
blitz and you know it was just I think
only a few years ago that us chests
added a blitz rating category before it
was just regular and quick and so I
don't think I couldn't tell you what my
blitz us chest rating is but I really
liked blitz a lot of people are divided
on it they're like well it's good for
playing outside casually but blitz
rating doesn't mean anything I think I
subscribe more to the idea that I think
it can mean something you know it's it
it shouldn't necessarily be it's not be
weighted the same as classical but it's
certainly worth something and I do enjoy
playing blitz talking about blitz caleb
is again finding very good counter play
and now Jonathan really needs to be on
his toes to defend against that deadly
Bishop d4 check that is about to happen
I'm wondering if he'll stop that
actually that's almost a must
now oh my god bishop takes me six huge
huge blunder
because Bishop D for now aloud and
Bishop d3 is coming and Bishop d3 is
coming no another heart breaking
oh my gosh that's gonna be it that's
gonna be it right well it's not made yet
but it's still in this nice slow painful
death here yes for I don't know what
Shakespeare would say here and I think
this I think the three prior games or no
this is the yeah this is the fifth
overall yeah so the the the previous two
blitz in the previous two rapid I think
they were all wins for white am i right
yes yes so this would be the first
victory for black and I realize quite
well everyone that I am jinxing a
potential victory here for Caleb and
based on what we've seen - no no no hey
this management crazy okay yeah thanks
mate may my goodness and Jonathan shruts
has been wrecked his reputation which
was on the line is ruined
he can never show his face on the
YouTube channel again by his own
admission my goodness he's got to be so
embarrassed because your champion of all
in Jonathan vs. Caleb is Caleb Denby 20
years old a st. Louis native from
Highland High School originally lived
here his whole life and one of the
club's favorite sons and you can see
them every Wednesday when it comes to
the road to 2000 and I'm sure he'll have
some extra pep in his step next
Wednesday and the next time you'll see
that it's live 6:00 p.m. right here on
the st. Louis Chess Club YouTube channel
well we want to have these players down
here to talk in the studio go over some
analysis maybe their favorite moments
and talk about how awesome caleb is
feeling and how crushed and devastated
and demoralized Jonathan
yeah but I do have to give it to
Jonathan he put a brilliant fight and it
wasn't 3:1 no I have to tell you this
wasn't 3:1 No
and according to the games it could have
been 3:1 for Jonathan mm-hmm well and it
way it turns out four and a half match
points total for Caleb Denby Jonathan
comes away with two and a half and so
it's that is that right I get that right
yeah yeah the winds were for white yeah
and there was the draw yeah okay so yeah
four and a half to two and a half yeah
okay well we have we always have
something big going on here at the st.
Louis chess club especially on our
YouTube channel remember every Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday night typically
we will have live lectures for the first
time ever we just started doing this
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Tuesday we
have my greatest losses where you see
grandmasters talk being forced to talk
about their greatest losses
that's from 6:30 to 7:30 we have on
Thursday night's viewers choice where
you can submit your games and the
Grandmaster looks them
that's from 6:30 to 7:30 and then at
7:30 to 8:30 Central Time
we have the Grandmaster look at games
from the Romantic area era any time
basically before the 20th century and
then of course every Wednesday 6:00 to
7:00 live on our YouTube channel the
road to 2000 with our champion of all in
Caleb Denby and Caleb is here in the
studio ready to be interviewed so while
we're getting him ready let's take a
look at at games here or should we go to
break let me know what we got to do here
all right well let's let's uh see the
aftermath of the tournament hall and
we'll be back in just a moment with
Caleb Denby are all in champion
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everyone and instead of the winner
we have the moral winner no events not
even know it's tough today
it's tough out there Caleb guy he's too
tough people were slamming you they
should tie me and you saw me play it's
yeah I would have to say yeah for this
and that they said that three one should
be the proper result but kind in fact I
disagree
you should have won one three is that
because I lost the games no you you lost
the games but you were winning the
matches yeah it's tough I mean it's I
feel like a lot of it comes down to two
fatigue really it was really tough just
playing this much Jess it doesn't seem
like a lot but but you know I don't know
just today was just it was a tough go
and I feel like I played well for most
of the game but that in fact I felt that
the lack of moral support during the
match felt he has a lot of fans a lot of
fans were there also the fact that he
came down as a comeback boy because he
just equalized at that moment and heard
resently he learned a lot from me oh but
the thing is that I can't read the trip
any of you had the issue of dealing with
time right what happened why why do you
guys get nervous at five minutes on the
clock
uh chess is hard and I don't like
playing it and I all my energy went into
that first game everything went into
that first game and then after that you
know I'm a dad of all these kids I get
tired yeah he's a young young man your
first game was brilliant thank you some
people right here called you god of
chess Wow
it's just unreasoning yeah but it was
amazing and actually I want to come I
showed this to Caleb all right well
let's do some chests I love chess yes so
let me load it up so at this moment yeah
rook b8
I assume you didn't expect what he was
trying to do as a root beer right what
nice III I see yeah of course
I thought I'd wondered a piece so I I
played up three so you played f3 and at
this moment and I'm I'm being very
polite here I'm asking the same exact
question that I asked Caleb mmm did you
think that you would become a meme after
playing f3
no no why not I don't know what you're
talking about it's a winning move
exactly might not be but I felt like
that de meme is on him
yeah yeah he put his night where I could
take it yeah I took it okay ah so this
was a deep cycle are you play by you
well I mean if he retreats he's
obviously like way worse so he's gonna
play 93 it was funny he said that he
should have gone away - oh you're just
worse yes and after here you were
confident that ya wasn't sure if I was
winning I definitely didn't see a win
for him mm-hmm so I you know I feel like
I must be doing at least okay here so I
was kind of amused and respectful
towards you going Bishop f4 was that
your first thought in this position that
HA Bishop f4 and that's it
yeah headset goner well no I had no idea
what the truth I mean I'm obviously
worried because maybe I'm getting
checkmated and there's some wine I'm
missing but no I thought I was doing
quite well after Bishop before I mean I
okay because I had already seen
considerably ship takes beaten well yeah
but it loses right I should be too man
if I take back you're taking with the
bishop thinking d1 yeah
there's a draw see Jonathan's a good
player he doesn't even consider draws
yeah well I mean I did see that end but
I thought maybe I'm winning yes bishop
Adam certainly not worse for was a boss
move rook takes takes and how did you
evaluate this so I I was pretty sure I
wasn't losing I think the question is am
i winning or not okay so I was I was
very happy here and okay
was already dreaming of victory 93 would
be five wickets - and was it like a
tactic that she spent a little time and
he spent like oceans yeah he didn't
think a lot but I mean he's got to
somehow justify this sacrifice yesterday
I just have to defend so and then you
just crushed him yeah obviously it's
like magnificent play you crushed him
yeah alright so I think the other
critical moment was this one came to
game of the Blitz okay yeah what I want
the Blitz here am i winning here do I
have some plan well I'm sure you're
familiar how many weaknesses your
opponent needs to lose to maybe yeah
okay
correct he has actually three so here I
understand why you went for the draw
yeah a lot of it too had to do with the
match obviously I didn't know I was
gonna like lose the next two games okay
but I mean it's just I don't know
whatever it doesn't make it wrong I was
I was actually looking to get back I
thought I'd get better positions with
white yeah black sari so I mean you
could have gone King yes I have an f5
yes it's quite clear now but and in the
heat of the moment yeah I see
or even f5s here cuz if you can't get
closer I'm sure that eventually yeah Evo
half and it was also ups us link a
slight amount of time so also flagon
came into consideration yeah it's just
the first blitz came and it was already
and I kind of noticed that like if you
would have slowed down you would have me
much in the match you would think yeah
yeah if you would have thought like oh
yeah hundred one or two more minutes
yeah hundred percent because in the
other games for discretion reasons I'm
not going to see you can say I'm sure
they're saying it here on YouTube what's
going on here so definitely you had
totally winning positions there and if
you would have my slow down and slow
down maybe win with a yeah and I felt
sometimes you played too aggressively
yeah when you could have been very
conservative just defending everything
in and actually that's what grandmasters
do they defend their stuff that's it
yeah
that's you know good they're not doing
anything just defending stuff and
therefore they winning yeah and even
though very good comeback the plan for
the last round mm-hmm so how do you feel
now feeling another match tomorrow I
feel I mean I feel okay I mean I didn't
look like okay it would be nice to get
into this someday when I'm in the proper
mood and I'm actually here at night I
don't know who would I'd play I play
Caleb again he's a he was a great
partner and this was a fantastic event
so I'm glad you guys are doing
commentary and want to get my big big
congrats to Caleb so he played pretty
well today - congrats to Caleb and after
the break we'll have the champion array
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis I'm here with a very special guest
Ben Simon alongside the champion of all
in 2019 the first ever no one can ever
say that again
Caleb Denby from Highland Illinois Caleb
what do you have to say first and
foremost to all of the chess fans out
there who had confidence in you and knew
you could do it uh yeah I just want to
say you know you don't have to play good
chess to win matches you just have to
you know play you just have to keep
playing even when you hang all your
pieces your opponent's sometimes thanks
checkmate back we just talked to
Jonathan in here and one of the points
that was brought up was the draw in the
in the blitz yeah did that surprise you
I was definitely surprised you offered
the draw I don't know he said that I had
a slight time edge but I didn't even
really notice that and like whoa I
didn't really think he was risking
anything in that position so it's
interesting I was definitely relieved to
get it but it wasn't like a shock or
anything so any moments you want to go
through in in any of the games uh well I
mean it's tough because I just I hung
all my pieces every game anything
interesting here so this is the second
blitz game oh yeah in the second blitz
blitz game here so obviously I hang this
nice e5 move which is just incredibly
obvious in hindsight so you know I'm
interested
I guess Queen d2 is just a huge huge
mistake but I wasn't sure what else I
should do instead cuz it's kind of
awkward already so I think maybe just
like a bishop c1 here for white I guess
that all sort ins in tonight c5 it's
interesting hmm yeah I don't know it was
an awkward position Jonathan definitely
improved over the the first game we had
in this line so it's you know this was I
was definitely a bit nervous here
already that's yeah I don't know I mean
the game's kind of speak for themselves
he played better early on and won some
material but then he would just I think
felt some nerves I felt some nerves as
well and you know
played a little bit too fast a little
bit too quickly and ran into some big
mistakes there was a lot of trash talk
going on before this match yeah and
sometimes after you see a big fight or a
big match in combat sports the guys come
out and they say hey good match man like
you know that was done that was done to
promote the fight or whatever but I know
that what we did was 100% real but what
would you say to Jonathan now uh yeah I
mean just just thanks for playing you
know it's it's it's a big deal to get
this match together and it's it's a lot
of work to you know try and prepare for
it and play and I had a great time doing
it
definitely got the adrenaline pump in
and you know it's it's all thanks to him
agreeing to do this and playing some
chess with me it's always a good time so
what's next for you uh uh you know I
guess I'm on to the next opponents to
you know find find out if there's
anybody in this town who can beat me in
a match yet it's yet to be done all
right well want to know and all in
history is pretty good and you can still
both both through you and Jonathan said
that there was so much on the line in
terms of the reputation yeah you know
where where does Jonathan go from you uh
well I imagine he's gonna quit his job
and leave the state but you know I'll
leave that up to him to decide but in
all serious in all seriousness I mean he
played very well he had a lot of winning
positions in most games if not ever
again so I he's got nothing to be
ashamed of leaving today would you give
him a rematch absolutely any time any
place I'll be here maybe we might see
that maybe you all into I know there's a
lot of people banging on the door though
Julian Pro Lake oh I'm looking at you
so hey who knows there's a lot more
coming down the pike and although you
don't win any money it was all about the
pride and glory in this event any final
words before we let you go oh yeah I
just want to thank Danny would you go
Thank You Ben
for us dents the group for all his
expert training even though he did end
up losing his his role there you know
and Jonathan same shortcut Perry Colson
everybody put this thing together
there's a lot of fun all right
well once again the champ Caleb Denby
all in it's all him and when we come
back we'll have final thoughts with me
and Dennis barouche
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello we're back for closing thoughts
here for the first ever all in Jonathan
vs. Caleb we have a champ his name is
Caleb Denby my name is Ben Simon he's
Grandmaster Danish Boros and what we saw
was youth emerging victorious over
experience what experience was putting
up a tough resistance yeah and I thought
it was a pretty good match I mean the
the betting odds according to Mike comer
favored Caleb Denby but but Jonathan
made it really entertaining and I'm
really glad that after both of the
rapids were completed the match was tied
because I that would have been really
lame if it was a sweep going into the
into the blitz right it's just taken but
I felt that this match could have become
thriller if Jonathan would have handled
his time better managed it and would
have used a bit more time when he was
already winning because he had many many
chances to come back to the game they
could have been any other different
reasons why he didn't but he was always
there chasing Caleb you know what I like
this match was really heated coming in
there was a rivalry on the line but even
with a five-minute no delay no increment
stipulation the players never had a
disagreement the arbiter never needed to
intervene it was a very gentlemanly
battle in the end it's a handshake that
settled it Caleb was the better man
today but he may not be in the future
we'll see what happens coming down the
pike we want to remind you though that
coming up in May the next time that we
are broadcasting a live chess event it's
going to be the first leg of the grand
chest tour 2019 it's bigger than ever
and we're gonna start it in Africa for
the first time in Cote d'Ivoire the
Ivory Coast will host 10 or 12 of the
world's best players in the first stop
on the grand Chester we can't wait to
bring it to you and I think we might
have it in Russian as well so for those
of you alternate language speakers be
sure to join us here at the st. Louis
Club YouTube channel and even more grand
chests or org so I think that's gonna do
it for today mr. baracs thank you for
being my partner we had I and we need to
do this again yeah sure good good team
so oh yes I might come er Mike comer has
made an appearance in the studio these
remind everyone to play the people we
are streaming like everyday on Twitch
here at the st. Louis chess club right
out of Studio B so check it out every
day except for Monday basically a tune
so yes
stay tuned stay tuned for that so until
May and cote ivoire for Grandmaster
Denis Perosh my name is Ben Simon we say
so long from the Show Me State
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you